all right we are back there we go and we
have a guest on with us soon here one
thing I hate to actually eat while we
have a guest on oh you know what I just
did I take this yet
I don't know this isn't a sponsor but
it's actually when people say what
supplements are I take very few
supplements or vitamins but they're
actually just something called KSM 66
it's the closest thing to like a natural
miracle drug really slash steroid yeah
decreases cortisol testosterone helps
your immune system helps with endurance
increases hemoglobin some more tests
other actual double-blind
placebo-controlled clinical trials so
anyway understand this right now to help
me with my energy we have our guests
hold on I know gosh I've been here for
13 hours give me a break
all right our next guest I love him you
love him he's also in the daily wire
Network and their tumblr mostly sucks
but his show is pretty good you love him
you fall it's the Andrew Clavin show at
Andrew Clavin on the Twitter mr. Clavin
can you hear us sir I don't think you
can hear us sound guy Edward all this
thumbs up and you hold on a second and
sound guy didn't even have this stuff at
write yet what's happening I would have
just taken the time to eat my
raspberries now I can hear you oh great
how are you mr. so much happier before
you I'm sorry I don't know if you know
what's been going on today you've been
briefed I heard that you were going to
sit in from CNN for 16 hours but I
thought even you are not that stupid
yeah well no you were wrong
[Music]
16 hours CNN what are we our 12 over 13
almost 13 no no coming up an hour 13
right 6:30 wait
we'll go it's coming up on eight we go
to midnight so our 12 Oh God well we
have four more hours yeah ah don't worry
it'll go by okay sorry Andrew I'll be
drinking but here's the one that we just
talked with Ben about it I don't know
where you are you in the same studio
there has been right now no I saw Ben
walked by outside I haven't talked to
him yet though I hadn't and I didn't
hear I didn't hear what you guys were
talking abut you look measure Bonnie God
oh he was he was sobbing terrible well
it's because we had some dirt on and we
let him know right before I leave all
right listen
that's true but we have sewing it let me
fill you in Andrew we have to do this
with all our guests I'm sorry let me
keep it really brief the CNN hit list
the reason we're doing this and the only
were able to do this has been set it to
live like welfare queens is because of
mug club we needed 16 hours for the
entire original CNN clock just to prove
how bad it is
how biased it is we hope we can only do
this kind of like change my mind
unedited watching it all day so people
can see how bad it is so let me give you
a really quick a hit list okay of what's
been going on today on CNN slow news day
you would think
not according to Blitzer so we started
the day where they were sucking of
stoking of course the Russian hysteria
idea that Trump was gonna fire Muller
then an Adam Schiff on regarding the
Muller probe's and Singh he has evidence
for nine months no evidence not one
single mention of uranium one despite it
being trending on Twitter all day they
said with the chip program Republicans
wanted to defund it and nine million
tiny tim's would die they used the word
nine million tiny thames yes they did
they actually said that and the funny
thing is of course no mention of the
fact that republicans actually want to
continue fight of funding the child
health care initiative for another five
years no mention of the melbourne
attacker being Afghani save Maori nori
if I'm pronouncing it correctly saying
he did it because of mistreatment of
Muslims they didn't mention the 1995
Israel vote at all to situate the
embassy in Jerusalem and recognize it as
its capital no mention of short term
funding from the Republicans until
January 19th remember they said we don't
need to shut down let's just extend this
to January 19th Democrats had to vote on
it but then when they finally did and
then it was kicked to the Senate of the
base that's going to happen they just
said Oh House votes no government
shutdown well you mean what the
Republicans pushed forward and then
finally breaking news currently
developing Bannon said that Bush 43 was
a destructive president and of course
that was actually said last October so
it seems to me breaking news on CNN is
uh it means lie your thoughts you're a
little too kind I think the fact the
fact that it took you 16 that's taking
you 16 hours to figure out the CNN is a
pack of lies is a little disturbing you
know they do did you know they do this I
think they showed a clip of Franken and
they'd said earlier but they meant
yesterday like they wouldn't news
usually say yesterday when someone says
earlier don't you think all this
happened earlier today so the tax bill
is off the news already right that's
gone yeah
they said that 9 million Tiny Tim's
would die because of the tax bill nine
million Tiny Tim Stein yeah is that is
that enough Tiny Tim's to kill I think
you know they can be Tiny Tim's can be
incredibly annoying
yeah million seems like a start but you
know you want there may be some escaping
you know they're always coughing I know
we want to fund a program to hunt them
down I think yeah I think you're right I
think you're right I'm just saying this
because that's gonna really mean tweek
and reclaim it so you gotta listen you
hear them you hear that word you know
god bless us everyone you got to rush to
the scene and just wipe them right off
the face well Tina you know tonight is
the premiere of YouTube Carol and we
have tiny not Kay Jarrod in there of
course we've just found out in the last
segment tiny knocking Jared was riddled
with aids down to his last 200 cd4 cells
so I see a crutch by the fire without a
tiny not gay Jared to use it when Howard
played for those Clint Howard played
YouTube CEO Susan Wojcicki in place of
the ghost of Marley it was Clint Howard
as Susan Wojcicki
as Marlon yeah it's a really messed up
special I I don't know how I missus you
know I did see I did see not gay Jerrod
as as the elfin that the shelf which I
find I have an elf on the shelf behind
me I find these the creepiest little
things they're supposed to you know they
you know what they're for are you
supposed to put them on the shelf and
they tell Santa Claus whether your kid
has been naughty or nice and so starting
that right there is kind of creepy and
then to have it be not gay Jared just
kind of amps the creep to it yeah tiny
NSA on the Shelf and if here's the thing
it's either complete lie or if it's
functional they're just millions of elf
on shelf sex tapes just ready to be
dropped at any moment in my studio has
seen things you would not believe yeah I
mean you were talking about you know you
were talking about Nikki Haley at the UN
that's that is my porn watching nikki
Haley slap the UN around it's like
spanking foreign to me I just want all I
want is for nikki Haley to wear leather
when she attacks the people of the UN
and I would be in heaven that would be
it at one point I just really sorry I'm
eating because I haven't even had a
break for dinner at one point what would
you give just for when nikki Haley was
doing her thing sitting there for
someone to object and just nikki Haley
look him dead in the
I just heard talking someone say I
object and her go shut up [ __ ] how much
would you get a whip is it too much is
it too much to ask that Nicki's given a
whip too when she goes can I beg for an
elf on my shelf
it is truly up on the Shelf is really
creepy I know that um you know you get
by the fireplace Christmas tree get
under the mistletoe I've my wife and I
and I turn to the elf and say don't you
look at me and I turn it around and then
three hours later it's been turned back
around no one knows that's way beyond
what anything I wanted to know and I
think I've in fact I think I just went
blind well yeah we're all on a second
let me cure let me let me cure what ails
you that's we did earlier we wanted to
see how many coffee beans we could fit
into I have a missing sternum take a
guess how many coffee beans we could fit
into my sternum oh yeah I know I
actually I actually knew that once wait
it'll come to me give me a second fit
into his empty sternum I learned that in
school but I just can't remember the
numbers seventy two hundred and a u-turn
u-turn code Jewish slash Christian let
me ask you what's your favorite there
isn't even being beer involved yet this
is just what happened we get tight it's
almost like a boxing match where we
talked about like the most dangerous
boxers when they're tired they're so
loose and now we're just winging them
and people like this this special have
gotten so much more fun well hold on to
your butts cuz gonna get a lot more
claiming what's your favorite moment of
the year like if you have to pick one
political moment of the year this is our
final episode this is our farewell it's
our goodbye yeah what's your favorite
moment of the year politically of 2017
this year I think I actually think it
has to be this this tax bill passing
because up until this moment I mean I
kept going on the air I didn't like
Trump you know when he ran I was really
opposed to him being nominated then I
thought well he's better than Hillary
okay so I'll vote for Trump cuz he's
better than Hillary but it's gonna be a
disaster
and then very slowly as the year went on
I started to think you know what this is
going pretty well you know we need to
score search and then we get some good
judges and then the regulatory rollback
right all the sudden it's just kind of
slowly slowly building but they kept
selling this idea that rally hasn't had
a legislative victory
when he bet that bill I just thought
this has been the best year for
conservatives since Reagan who I act you
know I can actually remember Reagan so I
mean this is the best year for
conservatives since Reagan it's it's
been an amazing year everything Trump
said he was gonna do and more he has
actually gotten done and you know he
hasn't done I and Colter is still
yelling about the wall at a wall but
nobody but nobody's coming across the
border anymore so yeah that's so scared
of them right that's right by the way
don't think I didn't notice that was a
prick comment he's like oh I can
actually remember Reagan implying that I
can't by hey but the joke's on you
you'll get dementia before I do so I'll
remember him for a longer period of time
you'll be ramming people with shopping
carts while I'll be talking about him
demanding course so the tax bill is you
know what I think you're right I think
it's last week politically has
definitely been the best of the year
because he's he's finally gotten some
stuff done um I'm a little upset with
the passive versus active income in the
tax bill I think it favors kind of
people in real estate a little bit more
than people in other businesses but
overall eighty percent of Americans are
going to see a tax break and that's the
crazy thing you've been talking about
with CNN they go breaking news poll most
Americans think they'll pay more under
Trump's plan but they're not eighty
percent of them okay and where did
people get that idea that's where they
should get the take the pole the pole
should be why do you think you'll pay
more so I saw it on CNN right they don't
take that poll you know that is the
important pole you know they have this
has been the year of misinformation the
news media one of one of trumps greatest
accomplishments has been destroying the
credibility of the news media I mean
they went after him they thought this is
gonna be easy you know we destroyed Mitt
Romney we went after george w bush we
called him Hitler this is gonna be and
he smushed them there now just there now
on self-destruct I mean Trump has this
magic quality that if you attack him
it's not that he destroys you it's that
you ultimately destroy yourself it's
like Marco Rubio with the small hands
comment when I was going to ended his
it ended his campaign CNN is now just
reporting stuff they're making stuff up
you know it's like God's right now right
now right now it says pence can't stop
hailing the chief that's the headline in
case you were wondering now they're
reading a tweet so sorry the ritual
submission in the exaltation is nearly
pornographic so it's it's editorializing
pence can't stop hailing the chief and
then they show a tweets based on CNN's
editorializing you just spent nine
million tiny things would guide you
crazy [ __ ]
sweetie Todd like they just manufactured
a plan to where they could just ingest
poop it out Riaan jest it like it's
never-ending Potter for that is an
unflattering angle quick get it get it
get it get it get it looks like it's the
orc when Peter Jackson got too lazy to
have a makeup department too sweet from
like two months ago and listen I don't
just like Rick Wilson I always never
Trump I think he's gone too far
but there read it they're reading a Rick
Wilson tweet on CNN four months ago this
is you know I hate to tell you this I
like it's not that I dislike the never
Trump's not that I think they're
dishonest I just think that they it's
time for them to reconsider this is this
I mean when when was the last time
something like this happened all these
judges sixty conservative judges right
you know this regulatory roll back which
is historic I know it's boring but it's
historic the judge what I mean what are
they waiting for when do you start being
like I like Donald yeah
he's you know I got you know what I
realized about Donald Trump he's a he's
a New York loudmouth kind of like me you
know like half the stuff he says half
the stuff he says it's just stuff that
New Yorkers say you know like stuff New
Yorkers say stuff that's funny because
it's so awful I agree he's a lot like
you he's kind of a dick I think
exactly bingo now you know I go back as
far as I'm like oh I think there might
be enough damage in the Republican Party
cuz he's because he's so unpopular he's
given them so much fodder then we may
never get another Republican again but
then it's counterbalance like this week
of ok once these legislative
accomplishments go through once you see
the fruits of the labor once people see
how much money they save right now
here's a 35 percent approval earning I
think it maybe might have been 37
because the majority of people don't
realize they'll pay less in taxes they
don't know like that lowering the
corporate tax rate just to be comparable
to the rest of the industrialized world
will result in more employment you know
they don't know that this alone fight
for 15 I think was Boeing Wells Fargo
AT&T Center low minimum wage now goes to
$15 an hour and we're giving out
millions in bonuses I think it might
take a while and then you know what
listen there may be hope for him yet but
rhetorically it's it's been bad and
that's why this last week I think was so
pivotal and the thing is the reality
does have a voice so at some point
people look around and say you know what
you know Nancy Pelosi told me tiny thing
with the eye and Tiny Tim is still
annoying me you know they told me that
the economy was gonna crash it didn't
crash they told me that I wasn't gonna
get a tax cut I did get a tax cut
eventually you know that starts to
filter into people's minds you know I
when I when I talk about Reagan you have
to remember they did exactly this to
Reagan he was an idiot he was a war
monger he was gonna blow up the world he
was a full actor he confute conflated
reality with the movies he was in they
said all this stuff about him every day
60 minutes did a whole thing about how
Ronald Reagan thought reality was the
movies and then you slowly started to
look around thought hey you know the
economy is ten times better and wasn't
the Berlin Wall standing there before
you know Ronald Reagan it was gonna fall
down and everybody said it was gonna be
a nuclear war reality has a voice and
album eventually if Trump is successful
as I think he's now going to be I think
people are gonna start to scratch their
chins and think maybe it's CNN yes the
problem well at least everyone who has a
layover in Atlanta who actually watches
CNN I think we're the only
they're talking to you and you're the
only person watching CNN who's not
catching a flight that's true and
sinneth in the thousands of people I
thought was 16 17 thousand people
watching us right now but you're right
reality has a voice and with Reagan that
it's a whisper more so it's a whisper
because it takes a little while to pick
up on it and with whistle Ronald Reagan
the whisper was Jimmy Carter's are puffy
and you're like what is that with it
Jimmy Carter's a person you're like oh
good okay we get it now so hopefully
that's what's gonna happen with Donald
Trump and who are they gonna run against
them they've got Methuselah and
Pocahontas you know they Sanders who may
actually may have passed away in the in
the since the campaign I think he I
think he's now you know just a corpse
and animated Medtronic corpse going now
we take everybody's money and give it to
the bull people okay great and then
Elizabeth Sanders who I could I would
pay money to watch her to pay that
Donald Trump I think moved a lap right
it's true Wolf Blitzer can't read
prompter claiming I don't think and see
he's the worst person at reading I don't
I I mean I this is just it's it's almost
like you could teach these hallways of
course in Antioch rity with Wolf Blitzer
but like hey mediocre choices 101 Wolf
Blitzer that would be the name of the
tumbler how many's all people working
acknowledge you're gonna I think my TV's
frozen it's oh no it's just wolf always
late what I just noticed they're Chiron
was official confirms commis account
that Trump asked for loyalty I don't
think anybody else was in the room when
that happen no no mccabe was and that's
by the way that's from yesterday 7.5
hours of questioning and McCain has said
I don't have any proof at all in Trump
dossier you know like hey yeah you know
there's any truth to call me saying that
Trump asked him to be loyal to him he's
like yeah I think that happened and
that's the breaking news now you
couldn't even get a story straight oh my
gosh I just you know what Blitzer look
everything that he does is a choice the
hair the glasses the beard um doesn't
moves the choice to drink a bucket of
saltwater before he goes on air so I
like the guy is out of his mind he's net
he's just
I don't think he's worse than Ron
Burgundy he's here all of Barnum news
commentary just aggressively mediocre
alright alright I think we five to get
going right we do have to get going
alright and reclaim and apparently have
them oh there's a story here today they
surprised me with some carolers by the
way hashtag crowd or CNN live so if you
could tweet it out that'd be much
appreciate we want to get this trending
just so that Don Lemon gets really mad
at his makeup artist and says so talk to
me leave me alone and runs away that'll
embarrass to say I think I tweeted that
out already very nice very nice so Don
Lemon knows we're here they're in the
building I don't know he sounds like a
for me else
John lemon wants to be a dentist so they
were somebody was gonna say before that
carolers all the carolers so we had
carolers come in I swear to you Gerald
can confirm this story Gerald say hi to
Andrew shut up okay so we had careless
careless hear that's the sickest
beautiful carolers Andrew really
talented three carolers come in they
sang a silent night
god rest ye merry gentlemen anyway long
story short they were like we can't sing
carol of the bells nothing well but I
love carol of the bells turns out there
were four carolers and the fourth gala
in the green room I [ __ ] you not had a
nervous breakdown when she saw me on the
monitor reveling and one of them was gay
who had a eyes for not gay Jared and the
other one was a fan is that my kids are
gonna say loves this so I only saw three
but there were four and one flat out
refused like she had to be helped out to
the car because she was so traumatized
at the mere idea of singing carol of the
bells to me you would've thought you
walked her into Hitler's bunker yeah I
have to be I have to be honest and I was
screaming like that too when they
carried me in here but there were just
too many of them and he was carried in
by carolers now this is a sex thing
we're going on we're going to Folsom all
right no it's true but that just goes to
show the left how far they've gone like
my Darrin you know the books the show
said listen what do you know about the
show what do you know about the show you
couldn't enjoy your diaphragm
you had to get a paper bag because
listen if you
um how about you go in this is a show
that's done like four hours have changed
my mind where I sit down with people who
want to physically hurt me she well so
this actually so we put out a poll and I
you know you used to be Jewish but now
you're you're a Gentile Christian
redeemed so I thought maybe you might
have a good perspective on this because
you've gone from miser to generous we
paid for a quartet do i prorate it and
take away a quarter of it well you know
as a Christian I'd have to say you
should forgive them as a Jew I gotta
tell you you sue if you claim in the
Andrew Klavan show at daily wired.com
Merry Christmas I'll say Happy Hanukkah
to cover my bases and happy new year
thanks so much in references to the case
Merry Christmas brother I'll see you
soon all right god bless that was nice
that was I knew it was a layout for yeah
exactly
the Jew god bless Andrew Clavin and Ben
Shapiro thanks guy
thanks for let me say hi I know I just
want to embarrass you publicly I hope it
wasn't that rude guys I'm sorry they
have to eat right now
nobody cares you are good hold on a
second it says on a schedule that
there's a surprise performance is this
Anderson Cooper right now no no he
hasn't time it is Anderson Cooper but
it's not him he's not on there so it's
Wolf Blitzer whoever it was just that
yeah yeah okay and I'm so during that
interview and I'm glad you ignore me but
the headline at 7:01 primetime headline
Mar Lago raises rates for me oh yes you
kidding me that's News primetime 7:01
couldn't care less
yeah exactly and they used a stock photo
of him from 2016 December 31st mic guys
something can anything be recent by the
way an important have your logo no we
went to Palm Beach my wife or knife is
it good no it's very gaudy well you
don't like gaudy remember that yeah yeah
that one oh yeah gosh yeah I was like
the Gottis lip there yeah tile ever
where I'm not a big fan of banal walls
have you ever seen Donald Trump's
penthouse in New York yes oh it is just
awful it's terrible
yes best era bad taste it's like that's
one claim that I will have a level
against them one criticism there's a lot
of crazy doesn't know our level again so
that's one but the fact that it looks
like Richie Rich's treehouse I think is
the most I know he's like reading comic
books he's like yeah we got to do that
by the way the people tuning in saying
why eating because I've been here since
8:00 a.m. that's right okay takes a lot
of effort okay and CNN screwed me they
screw you with bad line so let me tell
you that's not the only reason we're
able to do this and bio is trending this
morning we need to get it back up
turning so Donnell and his freaks out on
his makeup artist I want that tape I
want the Mel Gibson audio tape but if
Don Lemon screaming at a hairstylist
yeah
shut up sugar tits I told you that I
didn't want the deeper so we're always
and were able to do this is live workout
calm slash mug Club $99 annually 69 for
students veterans active military
entering the promo code if you're
student of life it's Christmas right now
we'll give it to you we are able to call
CNN on their bullcrap because we're not
beholden to sponsors who might pull from
us because we're not beholden to YouTube
who might try to throttle us all the big
supporters of net neutrality ironically
Facebook Twitter YouTube
they've been gunning for us for years
and thank you so much to people who do
it and by the way spend computer is
going to read out some more of you who
not now but later on who've joined a mug
Club because every time someone joins
mug Club Muhammad is raped in hell
oh my go I guess there's a surprise
performance we have a surprise
performance please tell me it's not was
it like is it something that do I need
it like what is this is it gonna spill
my drink no no you should go throw up no
no you're fine I'm not closing my eyes
driver close my eyes no you don't close
your eyes okay good okay all right so I
don't want you to feel alone everybody
but it tis the season to be a little bit
uh a little bit fruity for the gospel
here so what I'm thinking here is it's a
lot of time thinking about Christmas
yeah is it about Jesus or is this about
Santa Claus are you asking what yeah
what will say you well I know this is a
trick questions because I'm supposed to
say Jesus but corporate America is try
to convince us yes like both I like both
well to you well I mean it's definitely
about Jesus but I love me some Santa
Claus
yeah not like that Krampus she's a dick
well the tension has gone on for far too
long and I think it's time to resolve
the tension is it Jesus or Santa is
Easter Santa oh my god if this is what I
think it's gonna be I'm gonna lose my
mind
well Gerald are they gonna be midgets
please take the red chair Gerald okay
listen
hashtag Crowder CNN live stream if this
is what I think it's been like a
lifelong dream of mine and I am not even
gonna be feel bad about it I think it's
time to roll in tonight's guests all
right tonight's guests and here we go
the guests the guests are here
drum roll drum roll drum roll drum roll
drum roll let's go really oh I thought
you made like you're a fan of the show
but something Jesus would say yeah
thank you so much it's with a female
sinner and a male Jesus generally is
very touchy thank you very much for
being here Santa and Jesus thank you so
okay so I hear you're going to sit here
you gonna saddle up are you gonna settle
this who what Christmas is about
yes sir okay yes my child okay okay I'll
just I will just I'm gonna be a blank
canvas here because you have no idea how
excited I am for this Jesus versus Santa
okay I'll let you take the rings first
jesus take the wheel
oh boy Jesus will take the Bible okay
please listen now it happened in those
days you can see well you didn't sit
next to me if you'd like to right here
right here whatever is easy
please
Santa's camouflage with the red chair
but I think it's fine Trask camera thing
okay Jesus thank you very much Jesus who
wear glasses he's sorry well maybe you
should make that your next miracle LASIK
amen okay now it happened in those days
that a decree went out from Caesar
Augustus that all the world shall be
enrolled this was the first enrollment
made when King Harris was governor of
Syria all went to enroll themselves
everyone to his own City Joseph also
went up from Galilee out of the city of
Nazareth into Judea to the City of David
which is called Bethlehem because he was
of the house and family of David to
enroll himself with Mary who being
pregnant was pledged to be married to
him it happened why they were there that
the day had come that she should give
birth she brought forth her firstborn
son and she wrapped him in bands of
cloth and laid him in a feeding trough
because there was no room for them in
the end there were shepherds in the same
country staying in the field and keeping
watch by night over their flock behold
an angel of the Lord stood by them and
the glory of the Lord shone around them
and they were terrified the angel said
to them don't be afraid for behold I
bring you good news of great joy which
will be to be Stephen and to all the
people for there is born to you this day
in the City of David a savior who is
Christ the Lord this is the sign to you
you will find a baby wrapped in strips
of cloth lying in a feeding trough
suddenly there was with the angel a
multitude of the heavenly host praising
God in saying glory to God in the
highest on earth peace goodwill towards
Stephen okay so that's why customized
Bible thank you very much that would be
my Bible 1 the hill
that's why Stephen is in there can I ask
you did my wife give you those socks
depends on who your wife is sir yeah the
tall blonde lady in the green room well
I got ahold of mine
Jesus cannot tell a lie yes I knew it my
wife gave Jesus my socks I think it's
our biggest fight I'm like where are my
socks and she always you know I mean you
know listen Jesus you're a nice guy and
I just it's not you but my sweetheart
don't give even if it is Jesus don't
give my socks away I knew it was my
socks okay thank you so much Jesus I
really appreciate it by the way do you
need some water or something I know it's
probably hot in here
at this point I'm good okay at this
point you're good and then we have Santa
Santa Claus yep Santa okay so this is
him Jesus and now Santa Claus now what's
the what's the what's the the goal here
to see who okay okay good to know can I
can I ask you a question this is it's
kind of a sensitive but you don't know
what's it for little people what's the
right word cuz someone got mad at me and
said it's it's dwarf dwarf it is that's
correct okay a little person okay okay
all right all right
someone got mad at me once when I said
dwarf - so it seems like there's no
right way to say it God gives and God
forgets okay thank you very much okay
now we know so I just want to make sure
said you know you have to get that
awkward phase either way so it's worth
okay
thank you so much Santa let's hear your
origin story okay gonna read for you
it's gonna read from okay sorry I'll
take this I guess that's what saying
Jesus if you need some water
all right okay Jesus I might chime in a
little bit for the audience because you
know as we go you just got the last half
you say yeah you don't need to read the
whole story you got it all right twas
the night before Christmas when all
through the house not a creature was
stirring not even a mouse
yeah the stockings were hung by the
chimney with care in hopes that Saint
Nicholas would soon be there that's you
that's you come on now the children are
all nestled all snug in their beds while
visions of sugarplums danced in their
heads
and mamma in her kerchief and I in
my cap had just settled down for a long
winters nap all right I think we must
say I think you can skip to the rest of
the like the toward the end because
night before Christmas gets a little
gets a little long I'm not gonna lie we
all know how it ends well listen Jesus
was used to sermons on the mound yeah
we're on a time clock for CNN o'clock
here so he spoke not a word but went
straight to his work and filled all the
stockings and turned with a jerk and
laying his finger aside of his nose and
giving a nod up the chimney he rose he
sprang to his sleigh to his team gave a
whistle and all in a way they all flew
like the down of a thistle but I heard
him exclaim ere he drove out of sight
merry Christmas to all and with santa
amen I'm gonna be honest with you I
don't necessarily think that cleared up
a lot of confusion with the Santa and
Jesus bridges well I think we kind of
knew this it's a reasonable point but I
appreciate it very much the performance
informative our aspect of it that's why
it's to clear up some confusion and
settle this once and for all we have to
put this to a death match okay well I
don't want no one's gonna die in my
studio who's gonna die in your studio
that would be messy but uh we're gonna
settle this okay here now
all right forever I feel like you're
getting me up for something but now
you're building it up too much just out
with it what are we gonna do all right
it's time for Santa and in Jesus to
mud-wrestle and figgy pudding for
Christmas Wow
okay mud wrestle and figgy pudding for
christmas is there music going out to
the audience and I can't hear no no okay
now you're gonna have like a music like
final countdown play or some other cheek
okay with the rest oh you're not because
you're teaching me a lesson
correct okay okay one thing all right so
you prefer to off two little people well
everyone's
a little little person okay little
persons now what I know because I know
the turf well okay but is there any
reservation about about physically
assaulting a woman well I mean you're
both you're both dwarves little people
but one of you is male um this this is
just something you did right you feel
bad
oh well but I know but I mean you're
actually if you're actually gonna
wrestle in figgy pudding
my point is like it's not about to let
the little people think but you're gonna
wrestle a woman you're like the Andy
Kaufman of Jesus well you're okay with
this okay just want to make sure I'm not
forcing anyone to do like I said this is
where Jesus has to turn the other cheek
okay all right it sounds to me like
Jesus might take a dive well Jesus will
protect himself though okay gee okay all
right so let me move this here out of my
out of the way should I should I can I
sit here or joining a movie this seems
like a real I have the question would
you like to join us I can't join you
because I still have to go to midnight
yeah with what is this okay all right
okay it's not as messy as I this is uh
is this bubble tea bubbles just about
here's the disappointing truth I was so
excited while figgy pudding I didn't
know figgy pudding is that actually
pudding it's more like cake hey dude
layup make sure there's no water in
there just notice the bubbles this is
the bubbles okay all right so you're
gonna but it looks like figgy pudding
so Jesus and Santa are gonna wrestle and
figgy pudding to determine the true
meaning of Christmas eat your heart out
Linus is that figgy pudding
okay hold on a second let me see
breaking news FBI officials backs up
coming clean the present rump ask for
loyalty okay now just want to make sure
we weren't missing any breaking news
don't worry guys this stream is way more
entertaining than nothing has happened
if it does we'll let you know I hope
that figgy pudding yes I know I would
hope to as well all right guys you're
doing it are you gonna be able to clean
up after this oh yeah we're all playing
all right all right dude dude can we do
we have any music like to count them
down or something
lots of music okay how does it start all
right chair just don't just don't took
so long because the anticipation is
killing me and also they're on my [ __ ] I
don't want you like the fourth caroler
where I have to pay for somebody walks
out because they don't like you this is
three rounds three thirty second rounds
three thirty second round oh this is
sure a hit right at the Bell we're done
and Stephen Stephen okay you are a judge
this evening so you have to decide who's
the three three-minute rounds between
Santa and Jesus to determine the true
meaning of Christmas I missed the judge
okay well I think we should have a panel
of judges so I think you should be I
think it should be Jared and G and spend
will panel three judges that's how they
do it with boxing hold on a second all
on second on second is this is this a
round by round scoring or the totality
of the bout because you know we have a
we have a six five round must system in
MMA so what's required for like a 10-8
round between Jesus and Santa Jesus
Santa okay I tell you what I will award
extra extra points for puns for Santa /
Jesus related puns yeah or like a way to
manger
you know these are just suggestions feel
free to make them your own okay you
might need to help me through this
I love that you're committing to the
character thank you so much for this we
preach this is okay there's awesome it's
kind of cold in here but I'm gonna take
off his glasses yes okay I'll put these
right here I'll make sure not nothing
gets damaged believe this is cold yeah
I'm sorry I didn't realize we are we
just because we're going to be pudding
we should have one but they say you're
20 so like get going music all right
does anyone have any get going music do
you have anything this figgy pudding
froze it
it's a puck it's a Figgy puck they'll
throw it okay okay
rules okay rules of engagement you
cannot hit each other with the Figge
puck cuz that could cause serious
concussions and I don't want any
liability here in the studio no no are
you two like did you know have you known
each other for a long time are you are
you are you it and I choose some Santa
Claus and I'm okay alright I can see
there's no breaking you sir you're like
Daniel day-lewis and last of the
Mohicans only Jesus okay all right are
we ready count you down three rounds of
30 seconds between Jesus and Santa Claus
to find out the true meaning of
Christmas in five four three two go go
Christmas go home deck the halls go
double like oh she's stuffing it with a
straw how much let's go go reversal okay
time time about 30 seconds to your
corners to your corners to your
quarterly never Jack that's a Jack
Dempsey rule Jesus you got
you gotta give her time to recover okay
I gotta tell you I'm gonna be honest
with that round it was a draw
okay none of you scored any points yet
because he went for a takedown and he
defended perfect yeah yeah good sprawl
take him so Jesus if you want to get the
if you want to be a tribute you gotta
start chaining your takedowns with it
like a go for a low single I am I am
down for three seconds five seconds
these antenna recovered Jesus I
appreciate it I have to need a fixture
here this has been amazing but I have to
be honest there weren't any official
points scored now technically I have to
give you an advantage which isn't the
point but because you did get him with
four points of contact on the ground so
she make Santa sorry actually Santa made
Jesus work for it so Jesus you got right
now Jesus you got to go for broke you
got to end this
Jesus okay Jesus you gotta end this
otherwise Santa wins forevermore all
right are you both retching engine you
know the second good okay all right this
is really good this is really good okay
for the true meaning of Christmas
although red will all the red and green
chips remember I told you about cheating
takedowns five four three two
he got a pun
okay Jesus with his wig some cookies
thank you so much Jesus and Santa that
was awesome that was awesome this was
great
so listen I'm gonna be honest as much as
I love you Santa I'm kind of glad that
Jesus got the better of it because the
true meaning of the seasons Jesus made
up for it in tenacity so this was how'd
you do this a lot okay because we very
much appreciate it
and I know you guys were just words were
troopers here tonight because it was
cold in the studio it wasn't really
figgy pudding and I don't give a belt or
that we're on the belt so we should we
should go with a belt okay well thank
you so much I will tell you this we've
had a much better experience with you in
the carolers one of them was just with
just not having it and Jesus and Santa
thank you so much is that Jared are we
we're good thank you so much Jesus and
Santa thank you very much I need it all
of us needed Jesus and Santa thank you
so much we appreciate you being such
good sports everyone show us you love it
oh you know what wait right give me the
belt okay you know what Jesus on a
second let's get this let's give Jesus
is belt here Jesus has the Wonder Woman
belt Christmas now you gotta go over one
shoulder there you go I feel complete
now that completes you thank you
wrestling Jesus and wrestling Santa
Claus we appreciate it
Merry Christmas
Kwanza is not a real holiday it's all
about Christmas and the Jesus and Santa
you know what we probably need to roll
to after this so we're gonna go to the
fourth Christmas okay so everyone thank
you so much let us know your favorite
Mona the special right now we have to go
to segment four of the YouTube Christmas
Carol so when we last left Evan easer he
had been visited by ghost of Christmas
present past present and now of course
the scariest of all specters the ghost
of Christmas yet to come and segment
five will be at the finale of tonight
hash tag Crowder CNN live stream let us
know in the hash tag how you feel about
Santa and Jesus wrestling and enjoy
segment four of our many world series
premiere a YouTube Carol Petrified Evan
easer YouTube found himself to be a
praying man in a futile attempt to
bargain with death but he feared it to
be a fruitless endeavor for it is
appointed to a man once to die
[Music]
petrified urban easer YouTube found
himself to be a praying man in a futile
attempt to bargain with death but he
feared it to be a fruitless endeavor for
it is appointed to a man once to die
[Music]
our unit spirit of YouTube yet to come
Oh spirit I feel you more than any
Specter Viet Minh but I am prepared to
fight for thankful will hear us victory
oh yes yes not is waiting fast they
don't spirit
if you've got three million days with
only 48 hours
where'd you do that I uploaded it to
Vimeo for my praise of your loading game
oh bugger off gab demeo's players been
top now for years that's where you go if
you want to be seen but which has the
better interface well you could always
just understand spin this destiny of
YouTube might become my own death should
I continue on my path now show me some
tender mischievous world I've been
haunted by the terrible conversation
forever
oh yes very
sangguk ratchet antonio Jared's house oh
this is a place of great joy in laughter
thank you for bringing me it's so quiet
why is it so quiet spirit
[Music]
no spirit the aged spirit must there be
an awful Christmas it brings about the
scene like this how could we do it
spare mice we return to this place
or is it something else I must know is
that not true speak I must ask are these
the shadows of YouTube that 100 milli
the shadows of YouTube that may be okay
why would you talk about me skirt if
these events could not be changed
a website can be made right
attributive can be changed
[Music]
[Music]
with my boots
[Music]
[Music]
oh I was wrong all this time Rudolph
here we are in this storm and you the
misfit saved us I guess what I'm trying
to say is Rudolph with your nose so
bright won't you guide my sleigh - yeah
you're just using him now because you
need them during a storm what happens
when the weather's clear outside little
Rudolph here will be venison faster than
you can say Merry Christmas
okay so simply safes big selling point
is that it's mostly wireless and you can
install it even a dope like me in under
an hour or going to put that to the test
central location this is a central
location but there's my wife's essential
oil diffuser so I have to decide between
being safe potentially not loved
murdered raped in my sleep or the smell
of nutmeg this is my home no bad
hopefully we don't get robbed by any
midgets
[Music]
so that sound is clearly obnoxious but I
think that's the point took less than 40
minutes to get everything installed we
didn't have glass break sensors which in
one area will be useful so we're going
to order those and having worked with
other alarm systems that were wired into
a house this was a lot easier and
certainly seems reliable everything that
we've tested works
so simply safe calm / crowder you get
$200 off right now and I gotta say I'm
pretty impressed plus I have an excuse
to unplug the essential oil diffuser
which was really annoying I simply sing
complex
[Music]
all right we're back and so is hopper
good Lord that happened hashtag Crowder
CNN live should get it going I want Don
Lemon to come in here livid Hey look
breaking news on CNN right now bring up
the volume for people who can't hear un
voto hundred and twenty eight to nine
the condemned US Embassy moved to
Jerusalem and oh we're bringing back on
the John O Brennan tweed admonishing
president Trump for admonishing the UN
for admonishing his action in
recognizing the embassies and noticing
is admonishment of the tweet precisely
zero has changed since eight forty this
morning
now people who don't know and I think
what do you guys think of the dwarf
wrestling oh my gosh of course we're
always grateful to read your feedback we
have coming up next we have of course
you have former UFC fighter Chael Sonnen
yep current Bellator fighter so we
actually might have some you might have
some pointers you were trying to give
them some takedown advice again leverage
pieces I never thought I never thought I
would like lecture dwarf Jesus and how
to chain takedowns again did happen but
it did happen and let me tell you why
could we're mirroring this is what
psychologists called mirroring so the
level of absurdity on CNN Wolf Blitzer
the level of absurdity with their fake
news yes yeah I don't want you to drip
it all over your terrible iPad with a
certain level of absurdity here in the
studio yes this is what happens with
your brain on CNN for 12 hours it could
only be proven by watching it for 16
hours straight yeah there is no way to
any other way actually verify just how
bad this is and for the people for the
tens of thousands of people who stayed
with us all day or had us going yeah man
you guys are true thank you so much and
I really hope that for those who've
joined you feel that mug club has been
worth it because this is our first year
we went daily and we have been trying to
go above and beyond sometimes you fall
short did you mean to say refer to our
dwarf Jesus as troopers yes that was a
very conscious decision now where did
you get them I rent a [ __ ] DICOM was
it it was whether it rent a [ __ ] or
rented dwarf they didn't specify
actually
you said that was the URL he said
basically yes
basically the URL okay it's talent
agency so they're your frie or something
though I emailed them I'm like hey doing
a doing a production
I don't even specify Christmas they said
how many elves do you want they assume
that not me really they box them in but
they were they were super nice people by
the way to my super saw absolutely loved
it said they had a great time hope we
ride a Merry Christmas so all you people
sang this exploit did it I know people
[ __ ] about exit like something being
exploited if it's not the people who are
doing it well you got it you got to talk
to Hillary about this because she was
like I was so worried that when I went
in there to tell them what was going on
they were like oh no no that sounds
reasonable at least there's not like oil
and stuff like that she's like they're
kind of fine with it I guess this
happens she was she was a good-looking
Dame I couldn't really see much but they
were they were good-looking so I guess
they're a couple
they're couple they are they married
they're nodding they referred to his
girlfriend so I don't okay but a
good-looking couple and uh I I was uh I
was very surprised I'm glad you know
because people who don't know this
hashtag right are seen in Lakshmikant we
if you remember the story we went to
rent a dwarf calm and we wanted them for
CPAC one year and they said we think
what you're going to use this for
untoward purpose purpose as I said
you're you are rented dwarf calm please
do you tell me what purpose wouldn't
know any untoward yes for us to rent one
of your dwarves and by the way no one
wants to hurt them but listen let's be
honest do you not think that they know
that
rorf Santa and and and Jesus wrestling
is funny yes but also it's lost on them
if you put it in full people costumes
like normal-sized people doing it it's
not nearly as funny oh right so it's
it's all about the proportion they were
cool with it they were really nice
people ever the Christmas story there
well make sure we keep their card on
file because I gotta get a million
different videos look this isn't war for
Wall Street we're throwing them against
the bull's eye alright and betting money
on it you know they'll be watching this
right now on the way home let me go
check out this louder with Crowder and
their dicks so just know you're being
nice no you weren't being a normal human
but you heard it
now a goose hold on breaking news
breaking news former CIA director lashes
on a trump over threat to pull you in
funding over condemning this is an
actual headline breaking news former CIA
director lashes out at President Trump
over threat to pull UN funding over
condemning Jerusalem decision one more
time read it for you
breaking news former so not current
former CIA director lashes out at
President Trump over threats to pull UN
funding over condemning Jerusalem
decision do you laser couldn't be I've
some school there news programs like
middle school programs and news Perez
with more weighty news there couldn't be
a now coming up Pence is praise for the
beginning again oh my god really
Wow some people are mad that that the
Jews have a plot of land and the vice
president likes the president this is
news and these people have multi-million
dollar salaries I think Anderson Cooper
makes like 20 million a year what I'm
sure
oh we have our next guest ready the
other we have our next guest okay we
have our next guest ready to go tune
down the CNN a little bit of course he
is a former you have snow bad boy no we
don't have him that quite oh okay so we
are hi Lauren how are you I'm very good
how are you I'm doing well Merry
Christmas did you see your lead-in
segment before this
no I didn't we had we had dwarf Santa
and Jesus wrestle for the true meaning
of Christmas so we had a dwarf Jesus and
a dwarf Santa wrestle and figgy pudding
so true meaning of Christmas is still
Jesus he emerged victorious namely
because he was wrestling a woman he
feeds adore so that means the meaning of
Christmas
okay no they were both Wars they were
both dwarves Oh
Jesus was a dwarf as well Jesus dwarf
Santa dwarf didn't wrestling and figgy
pudding inter-gender champion Jesus won
on points three rounds Wow
yeah what happens if Jesus lost well I
pretty sure it's the rapture
that's not possible I'm pretty sure you
look I am C supported say the odds were
stacked in his favor
yeah oh my word miracles and such so you
know what's been happening right Lauren
we've been doing CNN first for all day
we do if we're doing it sixteen hours or
your art maybe are you aware of this are
you still alive or used to barely
scarily this is the ghost of Stephen
past these are merely reflections all
words just before this lauren it said
former CIA director lashes out over
trump over him threatening to pull you
and funding over a condemnation of his
so that's like I don't that I couldn't
think of a less action worthy phrase and
then it said coming up vice president
Pence's praise of Donald Trump so we
usually do a hit list but I'm gonna keep
with every single guest we've done a hit
list just as far as the most egregious
sins from CNN but they started off with
Russia Russia Russia and no proof about
the Muller issue Adam Schiff was on he's
been claiming he has evidence nine
months no evidence not one mention of
uranium one not once all day they said
with the chip program child health care
initiative nine million Tiny Tim's would
die then when they said okay looks like
isn't going to happen they didn't say
that 9 million Tiny Tim's would not die
no mention in the male born attacker
being in Afghani Saenuri who said he did
this because people weren't sympathetic
enough to Muslims they didn't mention
the 1995 Israel vote to recognize the
embassy in Jerusalem as its capital
apparently Bannon hates bush they said
this was breaking news even though this
was said in October and 45 seconds is
all they devoted to when Tiny Tim built
to when they basically said okay we're
not going to shut down the government
they were saying all day Republicans
gonna shut down the government and then
you said Oh House votes not shut down
the government they gave it 45 seconds
that has been the day on CNN nothing
else I just saved you 14 hours how do
you feel it is like four days until
Christmas shouldn't you be drinking hot
chocolate and sitting I mean you're
doing half of it right but the CNN that
seems sinful yes watching within the
week of Christmas although unfortunately
usually when people describe chocolate
is so delicious like it's so delicious
it's sinful so you're mixing I don't
know what that is I looked it's like
what do you I need to feel guilty I get
thin fillet delicious mmm you notice
that there you go now for it yeah yeah
good be I think they don't have their
priorities straight I don't think they
have a priorities straight either so
ain't Lauren what was your favorite
political moment of the year we've been
asking people
oh my favorite political moment of the
year well obviously it has to be Trump
winning and the great rapture a so to
speak for liberals yeah I didn't even
matter whether you like
or not if you're just anti-radical left
the insanity that they went through the
trumped arrangement syndrome was one of
the biggest lousy moment of the year but
that was 2016 more technically January
it's okay no was November when they had
the breakdown by January half them were
dead oh the inauguration I guess trial
deer appeal yeah yeah well there was a
net neutrality thing people lost their
mind over that that was another meltdown
oh the rules the Internet's gonna end so
I guess you have to pick something else
raishin okay
darn yeah 2016 man 2016 had all the best
moments 2017 got a little dark didn't it
it did it got dark quickly yeah but it
has it's been a good last two each other
up yeah it's been a good last time we
just happened I haven't seen any like
anti fun murders the kind of refugee
crisis has calmed down because the it's
cold they're not really coming over the
water anymore it's so favorite moment I
guess maybe the Battle of Berkeley that
was a lot of fun the Battle of Berkeley
okay the Battle of Berkeley that was fun
well hey didn't you because you and it
you and what kind of routes didn't you
do Ben Shapiro show recently
what's our only reason no I was on
Andrew Klavan
oh you're an Andrew Clavin show okay
because I know yeah I know that he was
over there at Daily wires so it seems I
know there were like a lot of splits in
2016 and it seems like people are kind
of making amends and do you think the
conservative coalition is kind of coming
back together oh yeah absolutely well
you know it's funny because I think that
Donald Trump was kind of like a dog
chasing a car for conservatives and
right-wingers they were they were
running so fast after it and then
they've caught it and they didn't really
know what to do when they caught it they
were all aligned for so long trying to
get Trump to win and then after that
they kind of went at each other's
throats for months and months and months
there was all the splits and all right
all lights in whatever you want to call
it whatever alt there is liberals
centrists
and now I feel things are finally coming
back together and people are saying
alright there's something bigger here
we're still battling for free speech
YouTube is shutting stuff down
people are getting banned Twitter's
doing great purges and we need to kind
of come back together and work towards
the same goals in fact to kind of figure
out what conservative means again right
yeah I guess that's I guess that's
that's a good point people are kind of
figuring it out now I think even Donald
Trump is figuring out I don't think he
knew what was going to happen this is
that's why this last week has really
been as outside of korsak has been his
first legislative accomplishment and you
know it's some stuff that I'm pretty
happy about we're talking with this the
embassy good thing the tax bill pretty
good thing doesn't really affect you
because you're Canadian you know I'm
sorry you guys still get screwed no I do
well they do well that works out well if
we do well you do well but your taxes
don't go down like when you see Trudeau
as your Prime Minister and you see
President Trump as obviously our
president I mean how much are the
therapy sessions that you need to pay
for it must be depressing
it must be depressing it was like
Americans we had Harper know what it is
is like when there was Harper in Canada
and Obama here it was the flip read like
man look at look at Canada they didn't
even have the housing bubble they had
Harper there even though it's like more
of a socialist country that really had a
prime minister who did well and now it's
flipped the shoe is on the northern foot
and we have President Trump and you have
Trudeau like is it really hard to
stomach do you think he's gonna win if
you were to run for reelection Trudeau
or do you think a lot of people regret
it because he's been such a boob
oh man this is the thing imagine how
powerful it would be if you had a
Conservative government in Canada and
America I know how we like Reagan and
Thatcher yes beautiful but I I do think
he has a very good chance of winning
again first of all because Canadians
don't really pay attention to politics
that much they just look at the shiny
hair and they're like well that's nice
put him on the front cover of all our
newspapers and worship him like a god
King Trudeau and also I don't think the
Conservative candidate is very strong I
like
all right but conservatism in Canada is
what you say he's all right for
candidate he's all right
oh I think he's all right like there's
no way and all right candidate would fly
in Canada no definitely not no he's all
right I think he's a nice guy but he's
an Andrew Shearer but I also don't think
he's quite strong enough to really
mobilize the same kind of movement that
Trump did so I'm hoping I'm hoping that
Trump's cultural influence and the kind
of culture of pro free-speech the jordan
peterson types will spread across the
canadian populace but it's gonna take a
bit longer than the Trump effect that's
for sure well let me ask you this
because we had Jordan Peterson on he was
the first guest
early this morning he's not really
conservative Jordan Peterson is just a
free speech guy do you see that changing
the culture on campus and can't hold on
second law second hold on breaking oh no
wait VP Pence is praise for the
president nevermind we don't need to
worry about it we want to make sure we
don't miss any breaking yeah I know I
know can you believe it the vice
president like said I like him I like
the president what's going on what's the
world coming to better go back to wolf
seems the vice president likes the
president back to you thank you most
embarrassing horrible I mean it took
this do did me watch their own program
to realize it do you feel like oh god I
wanna go home and watch any of us yes I
do no I do I think that I think Wolf
Blitzer it's like Larry Sanders and he
falls asleep watching himself with a
bottle of aspirin Astroglide next to the
bed I think Wolf Blitzer is such a
narcissist only time his mouth moves yes
so I will say this this wasn't so much
Jesus turn the other cheek it was it was
[ __ ] Jesus tearing up the temple oh
boy um I just can't grow an L for the
thing how bad did you think it had
gotten because I know you haven't
watched all day but it has been so bad
um let me ask you this like we're
talking with ben shapiro and andrew
claiming about this for example they run
clips and you just assume it's live it's
like they run a clip from al franken and
then halfway through the clip it says
earlier it was from yesterday when you
see something in the news lauren and it
says earlier is it just me or do you
assume that means earlier that day
I usually assume it means earlier that
day but I also I don't quite have the
stomach you do to watch CNN all day so
right I use cuz you're a spell that
other people sum it up for me so I don't
get ill yeah well listen I needed to
break with the carolers and the the the
the dwarf Santa and Jesus this day's not
getting any better
no probably God that was the highlight
and that's honestly I wish you two kept
because now I'm just gonna be depressed
a little bit I'm gonna be depressed the
Christmas that was almost amazing thing
I've ever sleep haha it's all downhill
from here
Jesus verses there verses Santa and
figgy pudding and some people have some
people were offended on Twitter like
Audrey or take advantage like they loved
their from rent a [ __ ] calm like what
do you think what do you like this is
how they work the one in the one in
Michigan it was legit leaked to brain to
dwarf like rants like it was wrong to
dwarf calm then higher yeah not not
watch just so I'm still trying to
understand I think the cut a highlight
reel two Dwarfs yes we hired two Dwarfs
and they wrestled right here in a kiddie
pool of figgy pudding to determine the
true spirit of Christmas
and Jesus beat up female Santa what is
hard about this Lauren I feel like I'm
explaining this not clearly as humanly
possible gosh you're supposed to be a
bright girl and then what else do we had
we had Carol okay here the true story
because a lot of you are just tuning in
now because people love you we had
carolers come in they surprised me with
carolers three carolers came in they
sang a Carol turns out there were
supposed to be for the fourth one in the
greenroom saw the monitor saw me started
convulsing in tears and said she
couldn't come in and sing for the
monster that is me and left had to be
helped oh she recognized you yes wait on
the spot yes yes no no she couldn't
heard like diaphragm was Britt on to the
doorsill well like I was hit like I was
Himmler and she collapsed like you know
a relative had just died and had to be
carried out and refused to perform this
is a very dark episode beating people up
know themselves
so that makes it better well we didn't
mean for it to happen I didn't mean for
someone to faint in my Sheila she left
it was you know she locked herself in
our green room so that we couldn't get
into our own green room just to cry over
the notion of starting a Christmas carol
for me the Christmas spirit is truly
dead in fairness though if you like we
talked about if you watch T now today
and you thought this is the equivalent
of singing you know joy to the world it
to Hitler right would you do it well
that's the thing when they say you know
you're being so politically divisive I'm
going well listen people know where
you're coming from people know where I'm
coming from to me what divides people is
when you have a 24-hour news cycle
that's dishonest and makes people
actually believe that the right is
Hitler or left the right actually you
know that was Italian Aryans that we
want to kill nine million penitents what
happens to her when she goes to her
Christmas dinner and her conservative
uncle walks in the room and she has to
sit there across from him I don't know
if you saw that college humor video
where it's it was Thanksgiving and the
guy has to defuse all the bombs across
the table because they keep bringing it
up topics like the NFL and the ceiling
and he's trying to defuse the TV bomb
and then someone brings up Trump and the
whole table is wired up with bombs and
he's like yeah yeah cNN has destroyed
Christmas for a lot of people I'm sure
if you someone convulsing in your green
room over the idea of singing joy to the
world to a happy man in a Santa suit I
know I know I even under a Carol I even
buttoned it and ruined carol of the
bells that's one of my favorites I was
like Carol the bells and I looked and
Jared was like this and I no idea what's
going on like what do you mean why can't
they do carol of the bells and then I
found out afterward it is it is scary we
were talking about this we kind of laugh
about it but when they say the country
is divided here's the thing me
interviewing Wendy Davis as a [ __ ] and
my hat flying off and her still not
catching on it's not gonna divide
anybody what divides people is the lies
by omission not covering the fact that
Republicans actually didn't want the
government shutdown put a bill forward
to the 19th not covering the fact that
Republicans do not want to cut ship they
do not want nine million Tiny Tim's dead
that's what truly vilifies people not me
doing a gag not you going in there and
doing some investigative journalism what
truly divides people is the constant
bombardment of lies I mean if you lived
in an airport and this is all you saw a
genuinely learn we're talking about this
we are all we all agreed we are the most
misinformed we have been in the news any
day of this year because CNN has been
our exclusive source of news and we
don't know anything we don't know what's
really going on you know you know it's
depressing beyond that is it's not only
an ideological divide because at least
with the ideological divide you can sit
down and if someone is willing even just
a little bit to talk to you you can
prove to them you're not a monster with
your words right but they've divided us
on gender and race as well all white
people are these evil oppressors who
want to kill you and start another
Fourth Reich or whatever and all women
and men it's all patriarchy so you just
see their gender you just either race
and get triggered and it's like I've
I've lost friends over this I know
people who have literally been
ostracized from their friend groups
because of their their their gender
because they're white they're not
allowed to be part of a certain college
club anymore and it's very very sad yeah
it's more than just ideology it's every
single dividing line they can possibly
find they're pushing us apart right no
you're you're absolutely right it is
amazing it says this is the post Obama
here we thought I was gonna be the
post-racial America instead it is the
most divided America has ever been in
our lifetime right away a black lives
matter you have patriarchy of Tralee
puffs you have carolers a caroler won't
come out by the way you saw it talk
about that this is the show that has
over five million plays and changed my
mind just completely unedited letting
people express their opinions and Darrin
and the greenroom said hey you know what
if you really don't I don't know what
you know about the show but if you
really disagree with me you couldn't go
out there and tell him and he'll talk
with you yeah and she ran it out crying
I can't I literally literally not
figuratively literally can't think of
any human being that I would break down
at the side of can you imagine I think
if I showed up to do a stand-up gig and
the guy said that's Keith Olbermann I
was like
like either one's gonna find me funny
but his producer said listen if you
disagree with Keith Oberman you can go
in and sit right next to him on the
recliner with a mug full of coffee and
have a talk with him you could not hold
me back
ya know I couldn't get out there fast
enough all right spring which we do have
to get going we have other guests to get
to and it has been a wonderful night so
Lauren southern at Lauren underscore
southern stay safe there in Canada
because I know they're gunning for you
with with the Millennials on the college
campus and the anti Jordan Petersons and
the LGBTQ AIP
so stay safe I'll do my best thank you
very much by the way this is just the
the ones he's gotten lose about the
teacher fat arm okay good let me check
this schedule here we have it is we're
forceps you in just one minute all right
Gerald and Jaron keep going here for a
second because I do have to you almost
disappointing things for me today
there's a week in general yeah figgy
pudding isn't actually putting no I
didn't know I had no idea I've been lied
to you for 27 years I'm sad that Stephen
didn't introduce me to Lauren southern
didn't just had the opportunity I was
sitting right here multiple times didn't
do it but back to pudding cake it would
be something else
muffin would be something else it was it
was rather disappointing but I didn't
even know that music including was a
thing that was good it was good it was
so still no news on CNN right now and
Trump and late-night is what we're
hearing like it's every single thing as
Trump don't don't you think they get
tired of this at some point no I don't
don't get tired of it at all that's the
problem like right now the war for
late-night
there is no war for less over you okay
lost you've all lost here's the deal
there's every other late-night host and
this show and that's all you need to
join a lot with credit calm /mo Club we
do the show we don't want you to we
don't want to be your only show we're
not doing 16-hour streams every day but
every night we want we're happy to be
the show you go to sleep with where you
can actually be informed and laugh
because let's look at the war for
late-night Stephen Colbert Jimmy Kimmel
Jimmy Fallon Seth Meyers
Samantha bee Trevor Noah am I missing
any there was that Larry Wilmore before
that there's that
Jordan Klepper I'm trying to think of
anyone else Conan O'Brien who's the
who's like RC karaoke yeah that curious
James Corden he's kind of a nine every
single one of Bill Maher is an open out
and about not only liberal but Democrat
endorsing celebrity and then there's mug
Club you can join a lotta with credit
calm slash mug club that's ninety nine
dollars annually six nine for students
veterans or active military just enter
in the word and if you're student of
life it's Christmas we'll give you that
one
and I think spend you're gonna have some
overlays pretty soon right up new people
who've joined yeah okay yeah are you
ready now
all right well listen plane people have
joined Mudd Club today and like we said
the only reason were able to call CNN in
there bullcrap
yeah the only reason we're able to fight
against Leyton at the war for late-night
I can't bring them up quite yet just say
no-oh-oh working with our guests but
we'll bring them up afterwards is
there's no there's no there's no cavalry
coming over the hill
no do you notice that's a word where I
often mess up cavalry and Calvary
because that's the place obviously Jesus
you someplace pray but I also say
s'posed you spend significant periods of
time in Canada you're doing good I do
say uh like like a I don't say dollars
but I realize like happens I'm so say
solace solace yeah I know it almost
sounds like so less you say Mike - Mike
I was I think about night night like
that happens yeah Mikey okay today is
actually a thing now is this like it's
not a commercial I thought it's just a
commercial so this is a whole this is a
segment they're doing there's a whole
segment the volume they're trying to
rally the country is if they speak for
most of the country with that's not true
by the way hashtags routers CNN
livestream I think we're making some
progress on getting this thing training
we have to keep going though you must
have more on a second here your fun okay
listen I don't care if we're trending
anymore Don Lemon knows we're here
that's just conceding all ground that
hey yeah I'm a person douchebags yeah
who these guys always go for diversity
like diversity of thought and idea and
they have zero diversity of thought or
idea gosh I know you're doing the
opposite day sarcasm I just don't have
the strength Gerald who's this guy why's
this guy talking this little weasel
looking guy
he looks like you ever watched the
Nutcracker and the rats that are
lifelike sighs come out like oh geez
they have a sword and it traumatizes you
as a kid
that's this guy a second I know hold on
he was sitting here right now Trump in
late night Trump in late night Trump in
late night what do you mean Trump in
late then we're trying to say late night
it's becomes a political bash for this
bastion of political voices and
countercultural you know why because of
you you guys are buddies with late-night
they appear on your show than you appear
on their show your watch Seth Meyers
show know it might as well be a CNN show
and Kamal bell had to show after Seth
Meyers I don't know which network and
that wasn't a nerville see I think John
Oliver is the funniest oh he's funny
I'm just saying he's terrible on fire
already
all right we're next guests Oh Trevor
Noah good there's a talentless hack and
by the way it's not a black thing it's a
talentless hack thing I'm not even
entirely sure he's black you'll take a
photo negative of Trevor Noah so our
next guest big fan former UFC bad boy
now fighter for Bellator host of his own
podcast which is wildly successful my
wife is coming in with food jail P son
and how are you sir I am I wish I could
say that this were under better
circumstances you've been made aware of
what we're doing today right I can't
believe it I mean that's that's torture
you should have had a good combo to have
to go through that ya know last year I
was waterboarded by your your former I
guess I wouldn't say opponent but your
former middleweight - competitor Tim
Kennedy I would much rather do that than
this that's not it yes well you do it
for entertainment and we do it as well
but in this case the only way to prove
how bad CNN was was to go through their
entire original clock to show people
that it's not just an isolated incident
it's the entire day I hate to do this
it's repetitive but I've got to brief
you on just a CNN hit list for what they
did today
if I came in 35 seconds okay chill you
ready do it all right Chris CNN they
started this morning with soaking the
rush of hysteria the idea that Trump was
gonna fire Muller even though he said he
wasn't going to fire Muller they didn't
mention it until later in the day
then Adam Schiff was under guarding the
mother probe
nine months ago he said there was
evidence there's been no evidence no
mention of uranium one despite it being
the number one trend on Twitter almost
all day not a mention once the chip
program trial here NIST initiative they
said nine million I quote Tiny Tim's
will die because of Republicans no
mention that the male born attacker was
Afghani named say you know worried who
said he was doing it because Muslims are
being mistreated they didn't mention it
all the 1995 Israel vote to put the
Israeli embassy in Jerusalem and was
supposed to be recognized earlier the
1999 and then of course no mention of
the short term funding for Republicans
to the January 19th they were talking
all day about the government shutdown
and then finally when the government
shutdown did not happen because what the
GOP put forward they just put in 45
seconds saying oh by the way nine
million Tiny Tim's might not die House
votes didn't mention there was something
Republicans put forward finally Mike
Pence apparently praises the president
that's been breaking news all day and
they said Bannon hates bush breaking
news breaking news developing Steve
Bannon said this in October chill has
anything that I've just said surprised
you and did you know it was this bad we
lost shell son of them I would bet my
bye throat hurts oh I already did it
with everyone all right okay sorry sorry
guys we're trying to get jail back on
I'm texting if we don't get jail back on
the phone we can play a game or some
like that right now it's like oh there
we go all right shall rightfully so
yourself included now we were about 15
seconds into a 35 second down that I
would love to hear the rest
oh god okay no mention of rent uranium
whenever they said that 9 million Tiny
Tim's I quote 9 million Tiny Tim's would
die because of Republicans wanted to
defund the chip program no Republican
has suggested that at all when senator
Rick Santorum was on saying that they
cut him off no mention the Melbourne
attacker was Afghani Signori who said he
was doing it specifically for Muslims
never mentioned the 1995 Israel though
when they were talking about it
regarding the embassy in Jerusalem being
its capital and of course when finally
in 45 seconds the government won't shut
down because of Republicans that have
said oh by the way Republicans don't
want to kill all the tiny Tim's and they
moved on to the fact that Bannon Steve
Bannon said Bush 43 was a bad president
and they said it with a breaking news
even though he said it in October
finally apparently Mike Pence likes
president Donald Trump and we had a
one-hour panel on that than any of this
surprise you and did you have any idea
how bad it was this is the entire day
summarized yeah no I did I I actually
watched them for about 15 minutes a day
they only do 15 minutes of news a day
and then the rest is just repeating the
same thing that's the news cycle with
all stations but yeah I mean it's
annoying and what are all these
congressmen gonna do that are calling
for Trump's impeachment because of
Russia once that bully gets proven that
it's all smoke and mirrors do they step
down I mean that's a tremendous claim
for them to make and stake their
reputations on it's not because they
move on and by the way
Steven can I tell you this I don't know
if you covered this but breaking news
you were fully aware that Al Franken is
not going to resign correct well it's
funny to mention that because they
showed his speech and it said earlier
now let me ask you this and I want you
to continue with your point it said
earlier in a show tournelle Franken
speech now when you watch the news jail
and it says earlier am I wrong to you
generally assume that that would mean
earlier that day a portion was from last
week how can you do that when your news
the most trusted name in news no I hear
you on that you know I reported this on
my own show the day after he gave that
I'm gonna resign in a few weeks I told
everybody him I'll be the first to break
it but he's not least even that's not
how resignations work it's not even held
firing works hey Steven you're fired a
month from now no it doesn't work that
way and it was so obvious actually we
said they had the Roy Warren debacle
going on and the Democrats needed look
really strong like we're anti this to
get Jones in there okay that work Al
Franken's not going anywhere he never
was the whole thing was a ruse I'm not
saying anything that everybody else
should already know but I do feel like I
am the first saying it and it's very
obvious well you know no weed well I
hate to cut your legs out from under you
but we actually we talked about this
earlier today I said no one says all
right I'm gonna quit I'm giving you two
weeks notice and then you just go in and
you take a crap on the photocopier
you're like hey al you took a crap on
the photocopier
we're gonna keep here for the next 12
days but just don't do it again later
the next day that's not how it like you
said that's not how it works it doesn't
happen so I'm just amazed he's allowed
to take the stage and just take a dump
over all Republicans this is doing the
keys of the place in that place exactly
he's using the key that's a whole nother
debate of him or whether he should we
can have that too I'm just letting you
know he's not yeah well I I don't know
about I don't know necessarily that he
should you know I know it was the war of
obviously when we were talking about you
and then more loss so people think he's
like I don't I don't know about the
picture with the breastplate like he was
a comedian at that time you know what I
mean like I think everyone would I don't
know I'm tired well let me make this
point then let me make this point I feel
like you might have already done it but
since I feel like this is the
appropriate show if you're tired I feel
like I have standing in this matter at
least a little bit because here in
fellas Lee ant Whedon Steven who he had
groped in that I worked with her we were
co-workers at UFC tonight and we still
have a good relationship and she does a
little show in California right every
time before I have a fight coming up so
you know my opinion might matter a
little bit because I am biased towards
her but here's what alhough on his side
he did wrong he admitted it but here's
the difference with him she accepted the
apology and she be had
that's honor that's honor amongst men if
the two people were standing the two
principles in the act came to terms it's
none of the rest of ours business I
think you know what I think that's a
good point I think that's very
inconsistent right now with the just
complete us-versus-them mindset of oh
it's like this nuclear arms race of
sexual harassment it's like listen I
don't care if a Republican does it or
Democrat what Harvey Weinstein Kevin
Spacey doesn't matter who it is this is
a dirtbag because someone needs to be
replaced but someone who took that
picture apologized and a lady said I
wasn't that big of a deal thanks I
accept it it doesn't matter whether it's
a democrat or republican that being said
there were some other allegations and Al
Franken's a prick so there is that the
other allegations I will agree I'll just
speak to that very first one and I'm not
sure he should resign either
there is a matter you know if you were
to take you know from what the president
went through or even Roy Moore was going
through there is a significant
difference when the voters know ahead of
time to really make their decision all
is forgiven and Al's case that came out
after the fact and some other people who
came out after the fact but if they want
to if they want to stick their bare heel
their heels in to leave it up to the
voters in the next cycle that's that's
fine too I don't know you know I guess
what I'm saying is if you say you're
gonna resign you got to go if you want
to man up and say I'm gonna fight this
thing that man up and fight the thing
but you can't do ball we gotta be able
to take it your word I hate to be
distracted child but I'm watching out
the CNN stream
hey that's pen computer really CLE Ellis
is our newest German Internet sven
computers fed make sure he can hear you
have you noticed the overlays a computer
oh you has a mouth fellow these
computers don't eat they only upgrade
their software dummy I'm tell me
something here's the thing man you
noticed fen there overlays are worse
than our show they just literally had
someone scrolling with a mouse on the
screen did you see that I mean that's
not what we're doing today that's what
we're doing today but we don't have
hundreds of millions of dollars and
Turner riding in on a yak that's not a
long beep oh my god you're asking the
wrong person because I can't see that to
eat screen phone oh that's true I mean
you have a podcast and it's very good by
the way where can people go to listen to
your podcast sorry I wasn't a big go to
iTunes it's called you're welcome go
enjoy ladies and gentlemen you're
welcome and it's a lot of a lot of
sports but you do get into politics you
do get into cultural issues but you have
a podcast is it just amazing to you how
marginal the gap is now between
viewership and quality with traditional
media and quote unquote new media it's
not new media anymore but when we look
at it and we look at these right now
it's the late night they're talking
about Trump and late night well there is
no Trump in late night it's all of late
night hates Trump and they have this the
Nutcracker rat looking fellow or Blenda
like Orlando Bloom just slept with a rat
they just haven't here's their he's
their reporter do you feel as though
it's it's really closed quickly in the
last like year and a half I mean you
were there early but now you're getting
you're getting far more people tuning
into you than CNN I mean that's got a
that's got to feel like an
accomplishment ya know I'm close CNN on
average that does one
seven million and I do about 1.6 so and
they've still got me but to your point I
you know I'm a little bit harder to find
you know same with you you've got what
two million followers just on YouTube
are real close to yeah it's a very
incredible thing but this is what you're
having to do if you want straight talk
anymore straight talk is out you've got
to be in the box Hollywood is probably
what is very interesting to me you know
Chelsea Handler on down in Chelsea
Hannah and I have the same manager and I
always wonder and I always try to ask
him is she a worker is she a hustler
that's just trying to turn a buck and
understands the concept like any good
carny that controversy creates cash or
is she really so absorbed with herself
when she makes claims like I'm gonna
leave the country instead of coming back
and going guys look on second thought
this is the greatest country in the
world I'm not going anywhere she comes
back with the audacity to say she can do
more good here Chelsea keep it up you
can keep it up and McGowan can keep it
up and and the Matt Damon and whatever
his body is they they claim they're just
friends if you don't attack slack they
can do this however they want to do it
but the bottom line is they're helping
they are so completely out of touch no
but they're not leaders of men and what
Steven what always happens is when you
have popular and famous people they then
think their leaders they think that
they're influential people they are not
jay-z can say it Arianna can say it from
the rooftops nobody's gonna go do it we
just want to be entertained by you we
don't want to be led by you well I think
sometimes that's you but I think some
people want to shut off and not like for
example that's why we do our shits a
late night entertainment show and we
also deal with politics because
sometimes people are looking for a haven
really our show is just a way for people
to tune in at night and not be
sucker-punched and watch a late-night
show right it's not really we don't even
do politics every night some nights we
do some nights we don't but a lot of
people want to shut off right that's why
late-night Carson kind of existed it was
a political but a lot of people now just
want to shut off all the time and so
they feel as though they're doing their
due-diligence if they tune into CNN
and we've exposed today this is what you
see when you tune in to CNN by the way
by the way by the way jailing jail
you're way off they're not even close to
1.7 million CNN it's not even close and
that's counting the airport down no no
no they've got they've got
up when I was at Fox redeye at 3:00 a.m.
was lucky to pull 400,000 viewers and
that was beating Anderson Cooper that
surprises me by the way what's behind
you you got a little bourbon back there
little grandpa's cough syrup we do we
have a little full bar back there
because it looks pretty nice it's very
rarely used and we have a full Christmas
set and something little something to
calm your nerves before you go drive
home no no definitely the studios no
chill you add a little bit she L doesn't
drink for people who don't know no see
people don't realize this is a dig and
I'm a wine guy and he's a wine guy he's
a simile gosh you know what you can kick
my butt Alexa it's true he played
football at Notre Dame jail you're
looking very skilled is there a fight
coming up oh you know what I got a fight
in less than 30 days I'm fighting
rampage in the forum and Los Angeles
that's right he's fighting Rampage
Jackson what surprises me is how much
you two used to hate each other now
civil it's been I know it surprised me
as well and I was letting him go first
and I thought things were gonna jump off
very quickly but they did not it turned
out I taught rampage in a good mood so I
went with it
yeah I think you know one thing that's
funny about rampage I hate to say this i
ravage great fighter but the guy is an
excuse King so a good example of
Washington interview one time because he
was failing to make weight you know but
I found out it's my thyroid and that's
what was making me sure I'm like dude I
have the worst thyroid problem in
existence and it doesn't just make you
like you're not fifty pounds overweight
mystical a thyroid no it's cuz reading
nutella sandwiches so listen I hope
chill that you that you win this fort
let me ask you what's your favorite
political moment of the year the way
before that the friend sorry it's late
jail it's late jail and obviously my
attention is all over the place we
actually just I wish you were here we
had [ __ ] Jesus and a [ __ ] Santa
wrestle and figgy pudding for the true
meaning of Christmas and well that's
what's interesting I was like wasn't it
is it a 10-8 must system is it what were
we talking about there were no points or
advantages until I advised Jesus because
he was going through the takedown and he
was a male by the way Santa was a female
yeah so it was intergeneric ampionship
with midgets she had a good sprawl and I
advised him to chain the takedown to no
go for it he was going for that low
single to the high crunch and then there
ended up being actually he went
risk and then Santa the female took
dwarf Jesus's back but then Jesus
reversed it so the true spirit of
Christmas is still Jesus here it was all
over the place quite a Mele over there
yes clearly we got a show where a Steven
was lecturing Jesus on takedowns you're
good well I was actually just sitting
there talking with my boxing coach the
other day he actually hit me with a
liver shot because I said and I know you
agree with me jail Chinatown was the
better film of godfather in Chinatown
and everyone gets furious when he said
you wrote that in your book and I agreed
with him but my boxing coach is Italian
and he hit me hard
explain your justification and then I'll
give you mine largely because of the
acting however those are both very good
movies and come on channel your thought
about in your book get more reasons than
that can I go back to the question I was
asked my favorite political moment of
2017 because I do have one it was a very
simple moment but on election night
when Hillary did not come out and
address her crowd and then her campaign
manager Podesta he comes out I mean it's
midnight it's 1:00 in the morning on the
East Coast and Podesta comes out to a
crowd of people that look like the cat
that just ain't the canary and he gives
them a fire of speech about get out
there and let's go win this election
it's like he's stupid the elections over
they're just counting the ballots you
can give all the pep talk you want about
let's go out there and stick it to
everybody else it's over dummy didn't
nobody tell you that that was my
favorite moment I just thought it was
great I thought it really showed what a
Miss they had going on over there
yeah well guess what I can't accept the
answer because that was 2016 twice
that's that what you're sure you haven't
been sucking back a little bit of my
grandpa's old cough medicine yourself
Wow January 20th I stand corrected mmm
that's a great moment okay so you have
it you have another two I can't watch
this late night in the age of trauma
there's nothing at the onset okay he's
still their favorite 2017 moment sale
2017 MA oh boy you know I had quite a
few I really like Trump speeches when
did Trump grabbed that that guy like the
Moroccan Emperor or something and he
grabbed it by the shoulders back
that was a gangster move I had no
problem with it okay all right I guess
we'll give you that one I would say
would we say this last uh this last week
I mean listen you're gonna we're we're
all gonna be doing better tax wise I
know you employ people right you're
gonna make some new hires with these tax
breaks you think that was a really big
well I was stunned when people thought
that that was going to be bad um and I
heard a guy on CNN come out today and he
was complaining because so many of these
tax breaks go to corporations and you're
just scratching your head going how do
you not understand this you know but
there's not very many people if you went
through and looked at there's not very
many people on the left that have ever
signed the front of a paycheck and they
just don't understand I'll tell you
right here in Oregon just our house but
in our house there's a super majority
for the Democrats not one Stephen none
literally none has ever signed the front
of a paycheck they have no idea what
it's like to go out there try to create
something take it to the marketplace and
sell it for a profit they have no idea
no and it's not that much different even
even federally that I mean they got that
Maxine Waters I mean come on she what do
you want to do there but I mean they're
just there you got these people in there
they don't know which way is up Nancy
Pelosi is another one is she's a good
strong member in fairness to Nancy she
does matter but she just is out of touch
with what it takes to feed somebody well
here's the thing though they're
completely out of touch you're right as
far as results in policy but it's kind
of like there's a fuse it's almost like
wolf of Wall Street with the quaaludes
where they're trying they're on the bike
and they're trying to get it to kick in
and they're going on I guess this one's
and then all of a sudden boom and it
hits 80% of Americans are getting a tax
break but we talk only 17% know that
they are so that's one thing when
Americans get a tax break it's all it's
kind of like an entitlement program it's
pretty tough for the next guy to come
back
instead we're going to increase your
taxes again so right now it's easy for
the media to carry the water because
people watching CNN think oh this is a
horrible plan then when they get their
tax returns eighty percent of Americans
are going to be changing their tune and
so I think there's a delayed fuse right
there right now it's easy to demonize
Trump but whether you're business owner
basically think if you're doing more
than forty thousand a year you're gonna
get a serious tax break if I'm not
mistaken serious and more people are
getting yeah it's right than that so
there's a there's a delayed fuse there
but Jay like you said they've never
signed the Front's of checks they signed
the backs of them Bernie Sanders has
been a professional couch surfer his
entire life Chael I know you ran for
office and I'm pretty sure you ran
against some career politicians there in
Oregon I don't know the topsy-turvy
world were living in okay different
subject chill I have a missing half of
this sternum guess how many coffee beans
I was able to fit in this 208 oh my gosh
yeah well no it's because it's actually
it's a it goes in and I'm missing FS
Turnham so you know that's one thing I
bet it would be a liability in MMA also
why you know it could possibly invert
into my organs jail could give you a leg
up in the porn industry so okay what do
you want to talk about I go I got two
questions my first is this ten minutes
ago you come in and my wife just brought
through there in here but I haven't seen
you eat anything what did she bring me
she didn't bring anything in for me well
no we we were given the opportunity to
step out a second act yeah she brought
it in for other people my wife is a
sweetheart well what is it I have no
idea for two things you're gonna know Oh
a chicken night knock your sharecenter
rotisserie chicken so there you go all
right second question how much longer do
you have to go how much longer you have
to hang in here it's 9:27 have to go
till midnight to nine hours two and a
half hours no no I'm not doing you're
welcome numbers with chance everybody
hates you listen come back or can you
come back before your fight not when
you're by the way 110 for people who
don't know this is how jail is jail one
time called him to the show back when it
was a local show in Ann Arbor's before
not cage era was even here was in
Detroit syndicated to a few Michigan
markets he was in the middle of cutting
weight you could hear it in his
he was miserable I was there for that
you were there I was there too and he
still called in anyway he sucked he was
off as he's so angry but he made the
effort he was such an angry man angry
too speaking up cutting away old
Shelby's got a new book out for the new
year everybody wants to lose weight diet
plants exercise the mentality it's a
four-pack revolution and gentlemen
remember you should never have a goal to
have a six pack six packs are for
teenagers and drug addicts I'm too young
man that's for pass I'll tell you how to
get it go to Barnes & Noble or right now
amazon.com I've had it with you all
kaboom kaboom I know he's gonna do that
he's gonna take down on his camera you
guys can watch right now I get his
picture me like son of a [ __ ] I broke
my webcam again buddy nail that you know
what he nailed his routine you know
what's funny about Jail he was a bad boy
in MMA everyone everyone who knows him
knows that he is Oh
breaking news what else communications
director Anthony scare Moochie resigns
no there they're doing no hold on that's
okay it would have bid though but
they're doing a montage of their
previous breaking news Kai Ron's right
yeah of course they're gonna bring him
up I don't think you I don't think you
can't see oh my god it's possible I am
so people thank you so much for being
with us and joining us a lot okay you
know what can we do the overlays of the
mountain Numo Club members spend
computer do that we have so many people
who joined up like we've said listen I
really open you know I'll read some of
your tweets I really hope that those who
joined the Mudd Club feel as though it's
been worth it we never wanted to be the
people you know this we did this we were
saying like listen the last thing we
want to do is be the bait and switch
people who give you free content and
then have you joined something you're
just getting the same thing that you
were getting for free we said if we're
gonna do it we're gonna build out a new
studio we're gonna go daily we're gonna
offer more free content than ever and
we're gonna start adding to it and not
gonna lie to you guys this whole team
they've really pulled together
everyone's been stretched really thin
myself included and so our next step
here is just to hire new people to
solidify what it is we're doing and then
stand then start adding on more
show start adding on more actual on-air
personalities you see with CR TV they
have Gavin McInnes throwing millennial
yep Andrew will cow but we need to hire
some people behind the scenes that's why
there's the golden ticket sweepstakes if
you join you'll be eligible at lottery
with creditor com
slash mug Club 99 annually 69 for
students veterans military if you're
student of life you're a student and
it's not I should say sweepstakes it's
not a sweepstakes but basically we have
too many people who watch the free show
right and so we get too many submissions
of people who have no business
submitting right so we do during the
paid show the nightly show that's where
we let people know hey we're looking for
an editor hey we're looking for a post
production manager hey we're looking for
whatever it is personal assistant
whatever it is we have a few new key
jobs and actually thanks to this tax
bill we might have more than we thought
yeah we knew for sure we were gonna hire
two new people in the new year and now
it might be three or four Wow pretty
good how about that how about that we're
gonna go for creating jobs who new taxes
all right screw you Democrats you know
all kidding aside all kidding aside
actually not all kidding aside you stink
how much spend computer Jared you guys
uh you guys paid more than fifteen an
hour right yes I feel pretty good about
man I am so bad at math it's a grateful
prick the sober point is these aren't
these aren't just bottom-of-the-barrel
jobs no when we hire people a lot of
crowder we really try to hire the right
people and we try to keep them in it's
it's it is a family business
and you pay well you you pay like I hope
everybody else who does the successful
business pays yeah just keep it all
yourself now the problem with that is
we've kept fewer people and paid more
you kind of have a choice right use a
finite amount of funds is something
liberal understand you could hire more
people pay them less or you can pay the
main people more and then start adding
to it with younger people who are paid
less than the other people more than 15
min hours to write fairly but now we
have other jobs and nuts that are more
entry-level jobs as well as one high
level job we'll be talking about behind
the paywall so those who join you have
an opportunity at a job because
we're always growing all right Sven
computer do you have do you have the
names or anything we have a couple of
name okay we have some people by the way
we promised you we would ring the bell
for people who joined Mudd Club it's a
commercial on CNN let's go I can't
mention the mole but we can't mention
them all but here's just a handful too
many so this is Jack Helsing ah Thank
You Jackie I'll sing I'll sing oh there
we go already oh this is Michael welcome
Coggins Jake Musil Mary Boyle Barry
Boyle unfortunate last name but thank
you William Vaughn that Connor hey by
the way make sure you're not giving away
any personal information here I'm doing
my best at stepping out to through two
and Bunker's Yonkers this is the final
one yes so much there we go
every time someone joins Mudd Club it's
a Wednesday inhale for Mohammed and
Wednesdays now go back rewind the
hashtag Crowder CNN livestream to see
the joke and get understand why hashtag
wins Mohammed Wednesday's is that well
we know there's no hashtags just
Mohammed hates Wednesday how about these
Wednesday there we go well listen I'd be
I'd be lying mrs. Edwards the point that
we were trending in the morning and then
not at night but it's also because I've
been going so long and I really I wasn't
hoping to turn them what we came out
strong but Chris Cuomo didn't show up to
work today I did a lot of material off
the table I know it really did John was
a dick yeah Papa John John way to go
Papa John and his Botox and his stupid
ways we have another guest is I want
another guest just a moment here oh
really
okay yeah hold on a second I don't I
don't see this here oh oh that's right I
forgot
okay by the way how bad is my voice you
know maybe take it I see yeah no you
still sound fun
all right food do you want us do you
want to you know I don't have time for a
break you guys do it I know are there
any other games we have planned yeah we
have some of it some more games okay
well let's do this guest I guess and
then we'll probably have to do the well
I guess there we go do the guests in the
game or then two guests in a game
probably guess in the game okay all
right
I can do that we have a guest in a game
let's turn up the volume a little bit so
we can see Trump and late night hey
there's Alec Baldwin doing the worst
Trump impression ever let me hear it
well is it going out to people all right
yeah Stephen Colbert the first time he
tried out Trump was during his SNL dress
rehearsal it's totally a caricature you
know you just pick a few things like I'm
sitting in the room I'm going your left
eyebrow up right eyebrow down that's not
how Trump does it although it's a it's a
horrible impression impression hold on a
second take away the expensive makeup
and it's an awful impression for mallik
fallen by the way I think his
performance in the edge is one of the
best in all of film take away the makeup
rape just pure crap who do we have we
have uh is it raise your fist no James
O'Keefe James O'Keefe James O'Keefe are
you there sir how are you hey good to be
with you no it's not it's not good for
us because I'm exhausted and I'm worried
we have two hours I'm 14 hours into CNN
James IV drip they said you had an IV
drip in your arm or something doing this
no I wish I had an IV drip I wish were
an IV drip of morphine and I just keep
hitting the button until I died because
we won't even do the prom sure you know
but basically everything CNN we already
just did the breakdown with with every
single guest every single breaking news
Chiron has been misleading flat-out
dishonest or actually something that
broke yesterday or in June or October
for example breaking news today
developing was Steve Bannon says Bush 43
was a destructive president he said that
in June or October October October what
was once in June Oh June was coming June
was call me saying that Donald Trump
asked for loyalty and they're acting as
though this was news they said that 9
million Tiny Tim's would die because of
Republicans they didn't mention at all
that the the the the attacker in
Melbourne was Muslim was an Afghani who
said he did it because of mystery not
one mention of uranium I mean are you
telling me that they are they've been
selectively editing is that what you're
telling me
yes exactly they've been selectively
editing but even worse it's just it's
like it's beyond comedy
they're not even trying to present news
anymore and today is a slow day and I
think that's because Trump's been on
good behavior but it has been the same
read it's just been the Russia probe all
day with nothing dude is that does it
surprise you have bad like we felt we
had to do this to show people that it's
not a once you know one-time occurrence
it's all day every day I mean you work
in this but are you aware of how bad it
is like would you be willing to watch
this for 16 hours to really figure it
out I I don't think the I think you're
doing a great I think you're doing a
great service I mean did you even watch
the did you ever watch the the the guy
who watched Russia TV or RT for like 24
hours straight someone actually I didn't
know if you were inspired by this but
some guys 10 or spell room okay someone
guys tetanus whatever and watched RT for
like three days straight to illustrate
the point that it's Russian propaganda
but this is what you're doing like I
mean I listen we did those videos inside
CNN where the guys like the things all
BS Russia stuff is not real ROM I don't
think people realize how how awful CNN
is and I think you're doing it kind of a
funny it's funny but it's also a good
service well we just had [ __ ] Santa
and [ __ ] Jesus wrestle and figgy
pudding Dwarfs sorry Dwarfs wrestle for
the true meaning of Christmas so you
know listen let's not without its perks
um Jesus won by the way so good for us
good for you know people and salvation
and no rapture let me ask you this James
what is your favorite political moment
of 2017 we've been asking every guest
this question 2017 if you have to pick
one or like a week or some kind of
accomplishment what would you pick I the
inauguration and I was in DC on the
inauguration they were like rioting in
the streets I felt like I was in Athens
Greece on like K Street and inauguration
and it was just an amazing moment it was
the forces of culture and crazy or you
felt like you were in Greece when they
announced that the retirement age had
been moved up from 49 to 52 and they
threw they had a riot you know because
those Greeks they always complain about
something I don't know what the actual
age was I'm search fend computer can
bring it up but it was absurd the
retirement age is unbelievably young and
they were reducing entitlements and
there were riots on everything so
inauguration that's right you were there
that's must have been pretty incredible
inauguration night what about this last
week would you say this ranks up there
with the tax bill and the embassy
Jerusalem oh oh yeah I mean it's it's um
it's but I think that my favorite moment
wasn't actually during 2017 it was
election night I was Hilton 2016 I was
at the Hilton and I was standing in the
Hilton when Trump announced his presence
one it was 2:40 in the morning I was
standing right up front and behind me
they were like you know 500 journalists
with their big with the big lights it
looks like Close Encounters of the Third
Kind whether huge lights and many of
them were actually sobbing yes they were
crying and they were so upset like today
no one had filmed them I took my iPhone
out and I started filming the sobbing
journalists it was almost unbelievable
I'll never forget it the rest of my life
Wow similar story fine we had carolers
coming tonight I've told that five times
I'll do the short version short version
is there were four carolers who came in
only three who were willing to sing the
fourth one ran out sobbing saying she
couldn't perform for me this monster
because she knew who I was and she
actually had to be helped up because she
like collapsed over the mere idea of
performing for notorious Nazi steven
crowder so this happened with me and
it's because of CNN when you just when
you paint your entire opposition as
Hitler
yes totalitarians people believe this
stuff they believe it they did it's the
Mueller stuff is this week to answer
your question about the Mueller stuff is
in my opinion based on the evidence I've
seen it's all just some type of fake and
a thing and they utilize CNN they
utilize these networks to you know
advance their propaganda and I know it I
know it's kind of funny but it's also
like really serious I mean they they
really have they've even had a lot of
viewers like 700,000 viewers oh they're
lucky yeah they're lucky to do that yeah
chill some photos like 1.7 million I'm
like you're out of your mind that would
be a good night for you know Hannity on
on Fox yeah no they they don't have a
whole lot of viewers and that's why it's
kind of it goes from funny to scary to
back to funny when you realize nobody
watches them sort of being in a layover
in Denver on frontier okay yeah these
numbers include their air that their
public spaces it includes being in
airports it includes being in bars so
really when you
move that almost nobody watches CNN
almost no one no but they have power
over there but they but those media
people talk to each other and you know
they have power over each other and
they're sort of losing their power but
they still have some power and the
Republicans are so afraid of being
shamed by them like they're governed by
the shame and the humiliation they might
face from networks right you know and
I'm like DC when you're surrounded by a
gaggle of reporters calling you racist
so they still have some power but not
over elections and not over the American
people yeah well I think they they're
they're kind of clasping to it right now
they're clutching to it these these
power covetous old sinner 'he's to put
it as Dickens as said it so I think
you're right James and is there anything
that you can tell us is on the horizon
at all or not where's you have to wait
and follow yeah I mean you know I'm just
gonna keep pissing people off you know I
know I'm here's to that we're going out
we're going up you know you're you're
focused on the media what's more
powerful than CNN the New York Times and
Washington Post and that's you know some
of these large companies out in
California and there's some there's some
big things coming in early January yeah
well we're we're it's funny this today
is media but for us they're talking
about late night right now really and
we're the only late-night alternative
we're not even really media we're just
like it's just we get to be honest
because we're not beholden to a 24-hour
[ __ ] news Club right that's really
what it comes down to yeah today we've
it has been a very painful Rahman
extremely beautiful reminder that she's
just the pure BS that is spewed without
consequence from CNN and thank God we're
a late-night comedy show we don't have
to do this every day because I'd want to
blow my brains out I wrecked I might
feel that way the next time I'm at a
layover in Denver it's that all right
listen project project very to us is
where people can find you and follow you
James thank you so much for making time
brother we appreciate you doing this and
we won't talk to you before then so
Merry Christmas and Happy New Year Merry
Christmas shameless book plug American
prob doubt January 16th American Pravda
out and I believe this will be on the
interwebs as well thank you James
O'Keefe you must go okay we have you
guys have food I guess for yourselves
you've got food waiting if you want it
can be brought in I also have a beer for
you if you
to have a little bit of a sip of that
doesn't know I don't want any blood in
honey yeah I don't want any of that I
tried I tried to offer a beer fresh
frosty beverage well he is something
different he is something different
doing I don't want don't plug it don't
plug it don't plug it they're not paying
for that space but I will say Walter huh
Walter Walter's our great new sponsor ah
but he wants me to punch you in the
balls but the problem is I have a gun he
has a gun Kyle a gun in front away so so
his razörfist not coming on the show did
we miss him attention so we got a little
while ago Reggie Fitz is at 10:15 yeah
oh oh so I see what we're supposed to
play before then Oh God
well that's why I should probably eat
before it yeah um you got a plate ready
it can be brought in or it can be you
know how about this you guys set it up
I'll eat a little bit of food apparently
I've never played this in my life not
gay Jared and Gerald Oh what we have set
up beer pong which some of us have to
play be sure these balls are washed yeah
I do not want to be I don't always want
disgusting non disinfected balls all
right I have to go grab I will grab
going minutes here for some food and
well let's go to a break you have a
break we can go to ok let's go by there
go to a break really quickly thanks to
our sponsors Walter and simply safe here
for this show and of course mug club and
then after this we are going to have
beer pong Pogo finale Dean Cain and then
the entire series and the last segment
of a YouTube care we will see you there
I'm gonna go get some food where there's
so many buttons no and now you're making
fun of me for that earlier
would you stand up and walk out on me
lay on me Oh years then I'll sing you a
song I will try not to sing
[Music]
I'm up here you big horse's ass haha
we're talking about I'll do it I'll jump
okay hold on just come down okay we love
you it's Christmas I don't believe you
all right okay hold on a second
do you believe in Christmas obviously do
you even Santa yes okay do you believe
in the mug club that people can join for
nine dollars annually or 69 annually if
their students bets or active military
gaining access to all of CR TV as well
as daily Crowder programming well of
course that's why I'm here okay well now
I'm asking you to believe in me just
come on down we'll talk about this
everyone wants to be together for
Christmas I could come down or I could
choose
[Music]
[Music]
oh boy help of the elf it's the
abominable snowman we better hide yes we
better find a place to cuddle what never
mind let's get out of here now hop on
slave boys objects you out of here oh
[Music]
nothing look who I found
I have nowhere to go you mean you miss
me but I thought you didn't want me no
more now do you have sympathy for I'm a
guard dog you mean it yeah we can work
together separate safe can help make me
a better guard dog of course it can't
replace me I don't know what I was
thinking
super safe can help monitor and one but
it can't scare and bite it bad guys like
that hopper can Oh No buggers quick
right everybody
[Music]
gee mr. dentist what is this place I
don't know it seems some kind of a
schvitz for toys toys
imperfect with exiled by Santa like
Hitler but a lot of you don't even look
like you have that serious a problem
yeah what's that asshats problem oh he's
a squirt gun Rudy Schutz jelly
he couldn't wrap his brain to solve that
one there's me a boat that kids stay
afloat you're a talking boat you can't
stay afloat you're not a boat anymore
you're a shipwreck Oh nobody wants to
play with a Charlie in the box okay
Charlie I'm gonna give you a pro tip
here if it's that much of a problem call
yourself jack dumbass the only way they
could even know your name is Charlie as
if you're telling them yes indeed yeah
thanks a lot guys we appreciate your
support hashtag Crowder's CNN live
stream let's go let's get that thing out
there you know what I did see one of the
hashtags that was trending or something
that was trending is appreciation what
is it short-girl appreciation day sure
cause you see that thing so what
technically would consist it would make
a short-girl like what's the what's
short what something cuz I'm like six
five so what now would be like how no
like five oh five five five four five
five five four is the average so by the
way we are still watching CNN this is
still there Trump and late-night yeah I
think they're really enjoying themselves
at this you're not missing anything
whatsoever this is actually better in my
opinion in the news that we've been
getting all day the news nothing's been
breaking nothing's been real news the
only thing that I think that we've seen
is that the Republicans actually passed
something right the tax bill hmm got
that taken care of but then they got
kind of lambasted for some of the stuff
that's been in it so they're never gonna
get any good credit and then it's from
Prussia Trump restaurant Prussia and
then pence loves Trump I think there's a
bromance going on right there this is
one of the things this is talk about
Gavin like when two people read the
exact same phrase but respectfully
differently so we're going can you
leave like late night every sort of a
bashing but like late night bashing
Trump every night it's a marathon all
day every day yeah terrible by the way I
I see I don't know if they can see the
the beer melon table I've never done it
yet
um reveal yet it's it looks really cool
by the way that the logo glasses are we
yeah
I've never actually played beer pong I
didn't drink until I was 26 years old so
I mean I I missed it at college and
there was nothing else to do at Notre
Dame but injure 26 and now you're in the
wine business 26 I didn't drink until I
started the wine business went to
ministry school and started a wine
business at the same time who says you
can't enjoy a beverage responsibly of
course lots of believe Jesus was a wine
maker first miracle wedding at Cana he
also drank wine
Last Supper said he's not gonna drink it
again so there you go I'm just saying
I'm stating my case so when the alcohol
starts to flow a little bit tonight
that's nobody's gonna be judging me no
at least they should no judgement at all
you Baptist can just go buy your own
liquor and do bidding I do each other in
the liquor store dudes are judging CNN
in their pile they call a day's work I
really I don't know how long it's gonna
take to get this out of my system and
I've only been here for maybe half the
time or a little under that right you
guys have been here all the time
yeah I don't know really like tomorrow I
really I'd be very very curious to see
how you are as a human being I am
playing for anything from a life pass
today have any appointments to cancel I
got nothing coming up I mean you need
the Brit orderly walks out you seem to
go I think I'm gonna go cry in the
corner of my shower and just stay in
there for a little while and hopes a
nice cold shower to wash this film no
I've cold why would you do cold oh it
seems more like desensitizing like more
numbing it's cold
exactly there's no benefit to that no
good lord
no well we thank you guys for being a
part of this the Mudd Club subscribers I
don't have to feel here in a mug which I
guess is a violation of protocol and I
also said you can hold the one that next
you pretend that's it right I guess I
could just say guys host yeah drink this
there is no post this is like that much
beer oh my gosh well I appreciate it
it's it's a lot of fun to do this you
know I Steve
obviously has a lot of the pressure of
the show and I get to come in and kind
of just be the happy guy that has a
business that comes in and talks about
really fun subjects but it's it's nice
to be able to do that so from somebody
who kind of gets in and out of this a
little bit the biases are real you guys
are not in like a bubble going oh my
gosh do we have perspective or do we not
you know I think part of that is because
you force yourself to bleach your
eyeballs at the end of the night but
because you've been looking at slate and
you've been looking at HuffPo and you've
been looking at all these really bad
left sights it shocks me when I'm gonna
meet people who like the thought of
reading a daily wire piece yeah or even
or fox news is just appalling to them
yeah not that I always agree with every
right-wing piece of content out there
but the balance like the idea of
striking charting fine balance but they
accept HuffPo as the baseline right it's
a standard for truth yeah and they kind
of adjust their scale for that which is
just crazy to me that they don't see
that it really is and I used to tell
people I said look I understand that Fox
is way right and I understand that MSNBC
and a few others are way left but at
least CNN seems to be more so in the
middle I usually think that way yeah
this was a couple of years ago and now I
honestly I haven't watched 2015 for me
yeah I thought seeing them was kind of
like the that's about kind of like the
it was a fairly reasonable they lean
left
they definitely left but they weren't
super super left and today I'm like
they're either too lazy or too stupid to
figure this out Yeah right and
somebody's still paying them money and
until that's that until it changes I
don't really think they're gonna change
it a happy marriage um I guess it's a
happy marriage of people who are
actively want to skew data effects and
information to not get the public what
they need and what they sign up for and
then they have a bunch of lazy workers
who are more than compliant yeah just to
do today and basically put that
confirmation bias yeah yeah you know to
shovel out what three like four topics
today maybe maybe for that 16 hours
worth of content yeah exactly make fun
of Trump and late night the entire is
this is great it's like going on our - I
believe I think this started it know it
started at eight o'clock all right we'll
see if it goes this isn't original
content they're just rerun you know it's
really interesting to a real you know
it's really funny this show wouldn't
exist if these guys were doing their
jobs if the mainstream media we're doing
their jobs shows like this wouldn't
really have a place there would probably
need now there's
there's a fun other aspect obviously
with the YouTube Christmas Carol there's
all kinds of great production I've seen
people on Twitter saying like guys you
need to be like a full-length movie like
this is really really good fun stuff and
I get what they're saying like I look at
it I'm really excited about it I've
missed a segment by the way I missed
right now if all of it towards the end
right all of it so probably about about
11:30 11:30 11:30 Eastern or Central
Eastern ok we will be running the
entirety of YouTube Carol so it's gonna
be it'll be great so yeah if you missed
any segments no worries you can either
rewind now or we all add one segment
after the other and around 11:00 11:30
so there's always there's always that
kind of material that you guys could
produce in the company and everything
else is fantastic but a lot of the
political stuff like half of what you do
would go away if the mainstream media
would do their job yeah and I hate
saying mainstream media like if media
outlets that we're supposed to trust
that say that we're balanced or that we
are fair that we're the voice of the
nation or whatever it is would actually
do their job and cover stories we
wouldn't have to do a 16 hour show where
we sit here and go mind-numbing ly crazy
with all of the stuff that we're seeing
right because we're trying we're trying
to pick through every single thing that
we see and say is this possibly news
like are they may be trying to do their
job here and just are missing the market
and here's here's the here's a point
there it's a slow news day I'll give see
and it is yes okay than that however it
doesn't get any better it gets if it
gets much worse on a busy news day
because that's when you get the most
inaccurate information then most the
late information the most skewing of the
dialog narration so yeah this is this is
actually CNN light compared they could
be talking about the heretics of the tax
plan even though they'd be standing it
up they could still be talking about
that and they choose not to they choose
to do other stuff go eat and take a
break they're still doing Trump and
late-night I said no because I said once
I left you didn't want to be I did not
want to thank you I want to come back
and sit here and watch CNN anymore I
just want to stay in the mud stay just a
dirty thank you so much to people when
we're watching and supporting I know
that I'm probably there was a huge
drop-off when I was gone because let's
be on edge pretty bad what I know we're
kidding
all right thank you guys so much whoa 30
we had a good time no game and then
razörfist
yes so we have a game here but the game
is preceded
by two presents oh wow look at Aaron the
intern in here it's per some hain camp
and the entire get in here buddy
oh gee the green room alright who's uh
well last year I gave you your presence
on air but this year they're not your
that's okay that's okay
last year I gave um is this gonna be
something like I open it up and it's
really like a pile of dog crap or don't
just spiders crawl on me Oh - dorri am I
gonna get cheese on your card that's
even better I feel like something really
bad is about that just draw your weapon
no okay I would be prepared to fire it's
a very it's okay I don't like I wouldn't
be mad I just want to know if I can
prepare cuz I'm like I'm sure that
that's not how this works
get up and open your present all right
so I'll open my first I'll make it up
I'll break the I give yourself a pro
gave myself right from you thanks on
your card nice pretty even sign the card
to himself
yeah she didn't have to have presents
well I can see was shipped to you here
we go oh my gosh that's crazy how did he
know how did you know well turkey 101 oh
no no no no no no no we're not playing
beer pong with Wild Turkey we're not
necessarily no no no no no I'm not doing
that I'm glad you got where'd you find a
bottle of Wild Turkey that small no
that's a travel size here by the way
people don't know this is a good example
okay
Wild Turkey is not a sponsor we've been
going after them to be a sponsor for a
long time because it is still the best
bang for your buck in bourbon out there
now there are some other Bourbons I'd
like that I will sell if but we've been
approaching wild turkey for a long time
they do not have any as matter of fact
they're probably mad that we're even
mentioning them no that's good bourbon
for the prowl start opening this that's
the I'm a medium come on I got it I
gotta be able to play with drive two
hours to go kill how you need to drink
foods to deal with that and the worst
part is I'm in a onesie
so I don't have my
with me which I usually have my Swiss
Army knife I replace it for a useless
gun well a gun without a you only rounds
in it so I don't want your switchblade
God knows how many four underneath you
turn it over turn it over it's open oh
but it's open its open okay open it up
false alarm
do I need like it's something gonna bite
me no I don't know but can you open it
over there it's it's not okay this makes
sense now it's actually looking back I
would have referred the spiders but if I
think the reason this is funny because
we were actually at Hawaii with love you
sir the the owner of Sierra partners of
course wonderful partners of CR TV in
Hawaii at his house it were like we're
gonna go on a kayak out to this island
and say yeah let's get some you know
let's get some sand I got a bottle of
Wild Turkey and knock kg I got a bottle
of kinky pinky Hawks are you serious
it's not a joke and here's the thing the
next morning they came out and they said
who Trey did you guys drink kinky pink
we move down the line everybody it was
like yeah it was like it was like a
bleep an effort in the pot the kids book
and he finally everyone put the pepper
in the pot only the differences the only
person who drank all of it was not gage
here yeah I didn't in one night these a
Teaching Fellow every idea for a
nostalgia sake but can we do it with
beer a little just little teeny steps a
little my team's micro shots it's like
micro aggressions yeah do you need this
Mike kind of turned tour oh we got the
above head there we go
I'm actually kind of bummed because I
got a gift a little Turkey or something
that would be like really cool and
crappy that's pretty much it well not
we're not I mean I'm sure it's somehow
they get something to see me here with
this lighting it's good we gotcha all
right yeah he's gotcha all right guys
okay hold on a second we want you to
tweet and spend computer you can bring
them tweet first okay who do you think
it's whoa I have never played gear pump
are these for sale these are not for
sale you better stay cool if these talk
about where are the camps on right here
no no no there we go now it is there we
go there we go Wow if you're gonna play
beer pong you need these
these dirty cups okay all I was like
I've never played micro shots micro
shots micro zip zip almost like if we do
this have to take off my Walter because
I don't think I like the idea
another no yeah yeah can't wear a drink
let alone being seen with kinky pink
well by the way Walter is completely
unloaded here so yeah let's dress it
many times many times many times all
right all right I was honestly looking
forward to getting in having a
refreshing beer so what happened do you
have to drink the wild turkey I haven't
read the kinky bath sure no no no no I'm
not gay
I don't agree kinky Pinkston if this
isn't fair
this isn't fair all right no I don't
even like this hold on one thing I know
you don't like it so it's better it's
better you okay Garrett are you drinking
man yes do you like bourbon yes okay
Eric Garrett the intern I want you to
taste pinky pink and tell me if this is
a fair blame whoever said it should be
fair like water falling just drink it
it's okay I'm a jerk I'm a socialist
that's really bad
yeah I mean that's really air and yet
he's gone behind the camera you ever
tasted this here I'll hold your camera
really quickly
all right look at it boom how bad is
this by the way this is late don't have
your kid don't you tease I know I'm
seriously getting Gerald still around oh
look I'm sorry I have a reputation to
echo thanks for watching CNN like an FBI
official claimed that Trump asked for
loads breaking on a second let's go
those camera okay I miss tail excitation
this is a line and they're saying
breaking news don't believe them and by
the way don't think I don't know what
the hell your day this tastes terrible
you're right yeah I know
don't think don't think I don't know
what's happening okay Nike Jerry's doing
the Trump he figures if I've watched CNN
all day right he's starting high oh come
on like kinky pink is not that bad no
it's still that bad yeah I don't want to
drink the kinky pink well I didn't drink
the kinky baby sponsorship from them one
cup that's terrible but one cup in the
rest of beer yeah yeah yeah get you some
beer there you go
put it in the hardest cup to hit now
that's the game I'll make it fair
alright Hasan you can you can video so
you can see I'm not cheating you know
what you want it's your healthy poor
there yeah right that's there's nothing
healthy about keeping ordinary no stop
it [ __ ] want to drink cake you think
don't brain it oh oh the winter white
okay that's good all I need a bottle
opener though I get another one right
here
I thought twisty okay right up there by
the stereo there get there it is right
there alright there we go okay so listen
I've never played beer but I don't even
know the rules to beer pong alright
genuinely don't know principal don't
suck that's that's the main role of it
no what is it what am I trying what's
the goal goal is to either think kind of
like bullying you and knock all my pins
down so it's one ball at time you get
one toss into the cup so if I land it in
the cup you have to drink that cup and
then that once we've I see your goal is
to eliminate all mine Michaels eliminate
all of yours okay so the rest of these
are really you win if it's beer that you
like definitely I find they don't pour
that much and then these are clean balls
either brand-new are they brand new or
the branded cups if they've been rinsed
since they were shipped did yeah I've
need any type of okay seal the plastic
so we're gonna do that where my balls
she said hey look it's Manju Raju no
it's not me it's the guy who lie about
Donald Trump jr. to give the Jenny
where's reference I got it
little race in it I got it a little
racist dude my kind of funny kind of
funny
Jonny Quest reference no super buddy
huggy yeah there you go cuz it's up
elaborate right yes we will forever
remain an intern you said it matter
forever man the intern who's been
operating $10,000 cameras at the lenses
that's the only thing ha Aaron's an
intern that's the only thing sillier
Merry Christmas
alright tweet your best to your best
reach your beds alright wheat your fats
who's gonna win that's a thing we gotta
tweet us and do we do a crowd or CNN I'm
stream driver CNN live stream ok I was
like a new rule new rule oh boy oh my
gosh the [ __ ] on CNN
looks like the female gremlin 17 hours
Wow
FBI director testifies for 17 hours it's
almost like you Steven
that's almost like you today John lemon
looks like dead Johnny Mathis oh that's
true what happened it's like you forgot
to threat his eyebrows tonight did I
start drinking what this just took a
weird turn done lemon okay when you buy
sugar weirder strip wells drunk well
strip the upon oh dear god no where you
know that's the point
this is that [ __ ] this someone's gonna
strangle Ben Shapiro can you tell me
about the [ __ ] it needs to be missus
name all right I need it better how many
balls that's true yeah well we're the
orange ones orange balls let's go let's
go the orange balls all right
orange balls just to get to raise our
fists and we have pogo Inc and in the
final seconds of the Christmas Carol
there we go all right thank you sir how
many are you doing how many balls that's
not a game there are no rules no there
are rules okay I don't care you know
first verse three he's not much of an
athlete you're gonna win ah
you guys both suck at beer pong come on
missed it do you have any kidding me
that's a terrible name for a drink by
the way thank you thankful chug it tell
you didn't you play beer pong him to
save a life well I think that was part
of their scene that is so bad I think
that was part of it now this Oh
yards gonna be hammered because this is
liquor and jeredy cannot hold his
alcohol remember he had a beer and a
half yeah I know I was waddling to the
restroom yeah
I don't like this that a training spend
computer just do it well what can you
factor this is that a [ __ ] on their
download shows I don't know the name is
give us a look here said Jarrod's dying
over I'm just really confused
my turn terrible decisions I don't feel
like this is why people are tuning in
but that is a [ __ ] no did I just say I
have another name Julia T national
security analyst no it's nobody tells us
the problems you're not a trained you
don't get the benefit of the doubt
anymore no Adam's apple looks like a
alright and I do think people like a
tweet us if you like this by the way if
you don't let us know as well but I
think people like Steven having pain
yeah right David Blaine not David
Copperfield no illusion right
by the way he tried to steal my wife
David Copperfield true story the one
backstage yeah sure sure about David
Copperfield well he does is he takes two
blondes and the crowd resume police
appear and just my wife didn't do it but
then they like disappeared he takes him
to his private island does what kinds of
weird stuff steps will make Harvey
Weinstein blush David Copperfield let's
go oh
airball gosh
hey by the way everybody's got bets on
Nagi Jarrod beating the crap at he is
well you know what so far they're right
he's he's uh he's doing it
alright here we go there we go there you
go making sure you can see oh I just
tripped over a power cord and no it's
not something doesn't have a beard no
Nets my chica hey look it's the guy from
Jonny Quest noses the guy who lied about
Eric trump down Tom jr. sorry Jared is
gonna ya ever get sold to me right yeah
no all right Hopper's boys are easier
for me you gonna have more cups to go
for a ball yes alright we might need
more balls you guys suck at this game
if it bounces off you'll need an account
after we're done so I'm gonna throw a
curveball here alright girl yeah he
heard that side help you brother by the
way I'm really ashamed because my dad is
Washington
I've never played beer pong in my life I
was not that kid in college but you know
what it's kind of fun to savor life
that's what I asked you it's kind of fun
you did beer pong there yeah that finger
though supposed to be the bad guy yeah
you were the baby
that's a sip of alcohol Klaus 22 yeah I
got you beat 26 nah just because I
didn't like it that's all
alright it was worn like the nice I'm
gonna write gosh oh that was close I got
one more so what have I gotten three is
it three three three three
okay three three go go go go go go let's
go there's a wild turkey everytime we're
recording alright reaction he's getting
worse at the game do dinner hope your
man card
yeah and it's already been declined
sound oh let's get get dangerous for my
gay Jerry pretty soon thanks recycle
recycle the ball for a second the ball
it's fine it's fine
oh here's think okay let's do it
five more balls my Beach that was one so
you had four more okay here we go
Farmar balls each player Jerry three
three oh four
yeah cs4 oh come on Steven this is the
Moneyball high five here is your drink
kinky pink that's funny that is a [ __ ]
on that TV that's why we're doing this
because I'm tired of CNN 69 for charity
and I don't care anymore
go ahead it's gonna be useless to that
one more each one more each one more age
cut you know you're screwed ah
Hopper's brawling at you so we'll get
him out of your soccer you can't have a
time till someone gets it all right you
didn't take your last shot all right
what a game
I hear ya that's a reaction to whiskey
that women want to hear yes I can hear
their ovaries drying out oh man I stay
away from that stuff for a reason yeah I
like it I don't want to do what I have
to do two more guests and so many people
were like I love this competition that's
the highlight of the night really not
widget Jesus well I guess it's a toss-up
oh all right guys get this stuff out of
here I keep going a little bit and
someone get my dog out here before you
model somebody's here today but he
doesn't like the yelling hopper is a
creature of habit and he's a creature of
low energy for people who don't know how
it is not like he's laying at my feet
yeah he's such a literally laying on you
likes doing that that's okay but that's
not lie to people guys remember hashtag
Crowder CNN livestream get it going out
there I know we've got just a little bit
longer yet what we've got - what the
hell he gave me two seconds and then he
jumps in it's just like the wine of the
day people wants you to be nice they
want you to be nice to me all right you
know taking a poll poll tells me oh now
you need me okay very nice spin hey spec
computer are we getting a lot of people
signing up for mug Club here now of
course we knew ones coming up from what
I can tell that's the legitimate women
that's a legitimate woman from what he
can tell you there's nothing trust him I
feel bad about it but [ __ ] have
ruined it for the rest of you
they have very difficult press of women
especially progressive women on see it
you need to understand we don't give me
the benefit of doubt anymore because I
don't want a lawsuit no we don't you see
a woman with big hands
it goes usually that's a burly woman now
it's like that's that person has to zoom
in and now you have to ask them like do
you want me to call you and that's
insulting enough right to a real woman
yeah
of course call me a woman what do you
think I did this at McDonald's the other
day at the drive-through I said hey
thanks man I'm driving away I'm like oh
god I don't even know if that wasn't man
you know in the middle now hey can we do
the overlays first do we have our next
guest all right let's do it Stan cool
you the overlays first oh we have yeah
we have three or four okay three or four
new bug Club members by the way this
whole thank you guys by the way you're
on applause for you guys for helping you
can hire them out for beer pong yes any
time you want and this was a bad mistake
consider they have eaten very little
today that's true no honest him fine I
know you've not really I'm so what
happened was ah okay let's see let's
let's go to my club silence first Fenn
who do we got laughter's better calm
slash mug Club and we have a bell for
hey I think some gay everyone can maybe
ticked on the some of the beer-pong
lights no we'll take them down in a
second on that all right go ahead fancy
some mug Club signups we have fur on
front Chuck there we go going to send in
a resume at Chapman Kevin thanks Kevin
Buckley bus 1 Pima man's friend what
humi man's right one that's that's every
time you sign up for mug Club it's a
Wednesday inhale for Mohammed check it
out and Anderson Cooper's paying him a
visit and dead Johnny Mathis look at Don
Lemon I am shocked
Donny L he doesn't look like the dotted
no is it just me doesn't look like that
Don Lemon I knew no no seriously that
doesn't even look like a different
person
well bit yeah well but I disappear maybe
no his eyebrows are thicker and his hair
it line doesn't look the same and he
looks old and tired like he looks like
Johnny Mathis died maybe he is old and
tired and Johnny Mathis was also a queen
just like him he's on CNN decennial
Johnny Mathis he said like he set like
track records so you know if he's got
his eye on you you can't outrun him this
guy looks like Dick Cheney knockoff
he almost does that's not this there's
no way that's 4k that's not a that's not
even HD what is this what kind of green
screen like it looks like they have a
tungsten light on him
looks like he's broadcasting from
somewhere where somebody about 18 feet
up is saying Arceneaux Nebraska ha ha hi
I can't I can't right now I'm
broadcasting from CNN in a 3 in a try
screen that is dead Johnny way until now
to get that took me all the way until
now I would say the funny thing that
happened all week was we went to
chick-fil-a me and my buddy John and
were just as early in the morning was
breakfast when we were really tired
at least we're gonna hint and I don't
know this probably is gonna be funny to
anybody but she was putting the food and
she asked about put like just want to
put the straws in the bag I told her I
said sure our little bird and she's
looked at me she if she stopped and she
looked back to her boss weirdest arch on
the bar I don't know why but it was the
funniest thing in the world to me
because I know she'll see you out in
public is it a dangerous thing by the
way don't ever play gay chicken with
Stephen no that's true never play gay
chicken it's like that scene rebel
without a cause only James Dean doesn't
throw himself out of the car it's just
two cars going over the cliff that's
right laughing you will you will always
outdo whoever you're around I know we
have our next guest I believe is
razörfist raise your fist I don't think
we have them up yet I'm trying to dial
them up razörfist and by the way I
apologize to the national security
analysts who in fact was not a
transgender or just a woman but who
could no no I apologize all right listen
that one is entirely on me and the LGBTQ
movement as a whole
yes come on sorry lady I'm sorry you're
you're beautiful in your own way here's
the deal we've been around so many
transgenders lately
yes bet it puts your mind Auto get
chastised
yes you get it wrong and so now you kind
of you kind of default to LGBTQ because
she's probably not gonna be that pissed
off at you what would I rather have okay
this woman mad at me for thinking she
was a man or this [ __ ] suing me for an
act of aggression for misgendering her
if that were the case right you know
he's just it's a risk you're pushing us
into a
guys this is what you get you're rolling
the fuzzy dice here's a further question
why aren't honestly why aren't wharves
considered a part of the their depressed
class well there is it's called height
ISM they call it a real thing but
they're not in the LGBTQ AIP silent
number know that sexual orientation beer
and a half in all remember going down
the bathroom yeah it was my one and a
half years come on you gotta tell me I
gotta play this guessing game every time
you put someone in a quadrant view on
CNN there's no way I can get it right
they got a lotta 4k I'm sorry just I
apologize seriously though
dwarves they don't you think don't you
think tours had it have it a lot harder
than uh do I think that dwarves have it
a lot harder than men who put on dresses
yes yes I do especially considering that
a guy puts on a dress and it's like the
Golden Gun in gold and I were in one
shot killed
there's no matter who else is on the
field you're done because this person
who's just claims the mantle of
transgender do you can't make fun of
them you can't say they look kind of
silly and even confirm if you can't
question their ideas whereas a dwarf you
can do all of things and you can pick
them up and throw them you can't do that
think about this for a second you may be
how hard it must be for them to conceal
carry think about it I don't think it's
fake carry fake you're a 380 it might as
well be a pig like s-cross hello but
he's so sick though you think that's all
thing if you're sick there's less room
to hide it that's true you need you need
a con you need a concave place a small
gun in your chest midgets are entirely
convex alright let's actually turn up
the CN n volume here to see if there's
anything that they have to say here did
Johnny Mathis speak comfort to me mate
it's not on the Senate floor yesterday
saying that the firing of robert muller
would be a red line for democrats and
senator Sheldon Whitehouse I was asked
about it
gosh can you imagine having to trot your
ass in tone this is something we watched
this earlier today do you think I know
you guys and here's another red thought
here's a really hard job but can you
guys having to try your ass into work
knowing this is what you're gonna do
that night now can you imagine this
pride-swallowing siege that Don Lemon
lives every day before he walked into a
show get the energy up for that see some
one of the last ones
yeah whole field seems wearing an
axillary softens up the beach why do we
even these red line anymore I mean we
need a new phrase relations nobody cares
about red line to really love you think
you boil down the entire content
actually knows that stuff the 16 hour
stream of live stream of CNN I think
yeah I think it would be very generous
with if you could boil down the entire
day to 15 minutes yeah if we did a
segment on the show covering everything
they talked about we would feel bad if
we went to 20 minutes long right yeah
yeah well homers like right now we have
a former White House Counsel oh yeah
former Nixon White House Counsel and
they give us Twitter handle like he
knows how to work that the kids I still
has the giant blue button VCR we're
supposed to believe that the the Nixon
White House aide knows how to use
Twitter all right we have our next guest
you like him we like him funny guy
clever guy and it's hard to say hard to
plug him because it's razor with a zero
fist he's on the youtubes he's on the
Twitter raise your fist mr. fist how are
you sir I'm fantastic I would have
shouted this out more but I'm actually
reporting live from Twitter jail right
now
oh gosh you were part you were part of
the purge yeah me anyone right a Stalin
isn't here with Milo Milo Milo is
getting passed around like a pack of
cigarettes in here straight that
strangest thing still has a smile on his
face
yes yes yes exactly yeah I you know it's
funny I I didn't get it tonight it's
because I think Facebook went after me
so hard and YouTube that Twitter's like
all right let's just let's avoid this
one for now there's too much there's too
much PR behind it so have they suspended
you or if they actually banned you oh
yeah that was my Christmas gift I got
the most ridiculous Twitter ban in the
long sad history of Twitter ban what was
your ban over I was banned over a ban I
was asked a name
they asked to name your favorite hair
doll guitarist this
Warren Demartini from rat or George
Lynch from Dakin oh no I
spots and I said Lynch all day every day
oh my gosh you didn't get to explain
yourself no I guess I guess the new
algorithm decided to take that one a
slightly different way I kind of like
isn't the name it's a command right
well I'm sorry yeah I guess I guess
that's what's going on well listen uh I
do I have to give him the bullet point
list no please the both yes we've been
watching CNN now we're coming up on our
15 and Russia probe Adam Schiff Muller
probe nine months no evidence they never
mention uranium one once they literally
said nine million Tiny Tim's will die
because Republicans want to defund the
chip program which they don't they add
never once today have they mentioned the
male born attacker was an Afghani Muslim
they'd say ignore who did it because the
mystery of Muslims they've been talking
about Israel without ever once
mentioning the 1995 Israel vote or the
fact that Jerusalem has always been the
capital of Israel and it's supposed to
be recognized as an embassy they also
said that Bannon hates George Bush
claiming this was breaking news in their
chyron money said it in June so October
jr. October I don't know anyway we
watched it all day and you know what
it's way worse than I thought
mr. fist sorry sorry to break up the
propaganda Thawne here well I mean
you've been unraveling the mystery of
where the pancake makeup ends no he
looks like dead Johnny Mathis he's on
right now no now it's a commercial like
there is every eight minutes on CNN
every eight minutes that's generous they
say oh my god how badly is Don Lemon
aged I'm like you can tell anything all
that like that that is just like a red
one when they eventually carbon-date
that cop that's a peel back like five
lights alone yeah Eric oh it's burst
well I think I think now you're gonna
get banned from YouTube because you just
threatened to cut lemon and a half if
you have to read the ring so that's the
only way to I don't think it I don't
think that carbon wait they don't carbon
date trees they do it by rings right am
i right yeah well you can carbon date it
as well I think he conflated analogies
but it was funny
I'm very tired I'm very tired mr. Fisk
but Don Lemon looks like dead Johnny
Mathis well we'll bring it up when he
comes back I I have honestly I have
never seen I haven't seen Don Lemon
since last New Year's when he was drunk
it looks like it's Johnny Browns be as
grand as he was hoping for he said I'm
gonna make more time for Mimi I've
mentioned it earlier with the I think my
favorite fake news today was the one
California scag saying Trump cutting our
taxes is and I quote like in crutches
out from under Tiny Tim yes yes sweetie
I think it's a little more like kicking
the government-subsidized Hoveround moto
scooter not be 500 around you know
Beluga yeah the one of the Grand Canyon
around so nice let Don know that did the
meantime and that great results no it's
not working
seems like homosexual activity in his
case sucks
like it's like Dark Crystal sucking the
soul out of you it just seems like it's
his life force but here's the thing
that's weird to me well they say time it
assumes the worst on Tiny Tim like hold
on a second there are some variables in
this analogy does Tiny Tim work there
are no labor laws in place back then
that's why Dickens basically had to
write his entire life he basically
worked until he was famous so this this
context matters if you kick out Tiny
Tim's crutch maybe you actually just
took him out of the being able to get to
work in which case I'm sure he was
probably very grateful for a tax cut you
know I don't know I don't think the
analogy works but um you know I maybe
I'm reading too much into it
oh I should also mention I didn't want
you to be alone in your appendix carry
today so I stepped on the ruger
sympathetically OH
well they well you gotta get yourself a
Walther and I don't just say that
because what do you have the LCP is that
what's going on no no no this is a
revolver but oh I just read funk is it
the SP 101 or the LCP no no this is a
ruger blackhawk this is a this is a yeah
okay you can't really go an old-timey
I'm about to have a shoot at Matt at the
OK Corral yeah I was gonna say you can't
really appendix carry that by the way
you know it's [ __ ] you ever watch
butch catch Butch Cassidy and the
Sundance Kid
not if you watch Butch Cassidy and
Sundance Kid as a child and you don't
know how it ends
it is the
first motion picture experience of your
life it's bad we're like okay they're
gearing up here at the end looking at me
why no that's this is the end
I'd rather doc holliday die of TB in
front of me Oh Joe just august osage
county which could not end soon enough I
don't know why you would subject
yourself to that the kinky pink it was a
dusty Osage County possibly the worst of
their so uh raise your fist Jared Mackey
George drunk
we played beer pong I need to add up to
use wild turkey it's nice option you've
got a little in you to Steven yeah yeah
you're tired that's the I am tired
alcohol fix the body red-nosed going on
it's that time here we're tired
razor razor carry us what's your
favorite 2017 we're going to the
homestretch what's your favorite moment
of 2017 I feel like officer Lahey get
what's your favorite moment Randy don't
say the election for the third time and
he died this year too that's that's not
my favorite game Lahey died
yeah yeah he's gone it's gone Daddy gone
supposed to carry your ass yeah I do not
have good luck with I'm over two with
noticing the subtleties of Matt Iseman
okay
you're mm let's ignore officer Jim Lahey
I'm gonna have to go google that I had
no idea I was just watching trailer boys
the other night Hey look Kirsten powers
she went after me on Twitter because I
said something entirely accurate when I
called Hillary Clinton the [ __ ] haha
dead Johnny Mathis razörfist what is
your favorite 2017 moment politically I
think oh you know the tiny the kicking
crunch is out from underneath Tiny Tim
moment is a close one I would it would
have to be a top contender that that has
to be the height of Trump derangement
syndrome at this point right and you're
not even a triumph and go in there what
was that you've got a pretty good list
go in there with with the CNN coverage I
know I also care what are you doing on
your phone checking Twitter to see what
people are saying about the good little
scat chicken Twitter if you stopped
checking Twitter I'm not checking I
literally I'm the opposite of Twitter's
is a text and my research document and
Kirsten powers is on screen hey let me
ask you this okay
razor fist I just saw that National
Security Advisor I don't if you were
watching CNN was sure it was a [ __ ]
can we acknowledge that the unsung
heroes were the victims in all of this
women who are larger like women who are
big-boned let's admit can we all admit
we never give them the benefit of the
doubt anymore I'm okay with affirmative
action for the discipline but seriously
a long time enough you sell them with
bigger hands you're like oh that's just
a bigger woman and now right away to
avoid a lawsuit you're like uh I'm just
gonna go gender-neutral until I figure
this out you you this Seinfeld man-hands
episode could not be made 2017 no
absolutely not because the hey man hands
are we breaking a lobster and then the
camera pans there's a penis it really is
like honestly it's really hard to to
give them the benefit of the doubt
because each and every one is so guarded
nowadays so Tiny Tim crutches okay but
throughout the whole year oh listen let
me ask us you didn't you haven't you had
a big debate this year with some
liberals right on youtube and I remember
you plugging it what was it
yeah well I actually did have fun we're
at the debate but it was it was with
secular talk who I didn't know from Adam
and still don't I baked with my own
wedges I have no no idea what that is
but you like the guy who ducked you a
bunch of times I believe okay
oh-oh-oh secular talk secular talk yeah
he's in the Young Turks Network that's
right okay yeah you in a debate that's
right I remember that and and yeah and I
remember I remember you telling me about
it and plugging the show I didn't have a
ton of time so kind of tuned in and they
used what I we've talked about is the
single greatest falsehood in the
healthcare debate said well if you look
at health care is actually better in
boom Finland boom Canada boom and they
don't mention Cuba anymore which they
did for a long time because of Michael
Morgan because the only
statistics they can point to are
subjective measurements people being
polled on if they like their health care
and I noticed that being used quite a
few times and you just didn't have a
time to get a word in on that and
that's the biggest bait and switch the
left uses with healthcare yeah the
biggest problem was he was he was like a
headline machine gun you know it was
like I I have Google too if I wanted to
just rattle off headlines I thought we
were gonna state our arguments and Ren
just responded the Sarge depends see
Google is a very common app I don't know
if you're aware but yeah that that was
an interesting one I think you're
missing I don't think it's really an app
it's a cert good lord
they haven't had enough oh yeah I guess
I do have okay you're right I'll give
you that one ratcheting they have an app
I would say with the iPhone we're like
battered women it's like oh gosh like
the I like it's gotten so bad now right
but it's like no no we're like okay it's
gotten slow and even though they
supported that neutrality now they're
slowing down old phones and no one even
calls them on it just like Google and
YouTube and then it's just like they're
like you bet you'll never find anyone
better you already pay for all these
iTunes and these apps and you're like ah
you're right
I'm like Julia Roberts and sleeping with
the enemy I have to swim out at dusk
it's so bad like I know that it's gotten
bad this keyboard for the iPad is soap
look at this origami crap and I have to
use it this is a keyboard for the iPad
pro 10.5 and only Apple makes it and
they Church one hundred and fifty
dollars and I got it because I was going
on a business trip where I needed a
keyboard because I don't have a laptop
it is so bad I'm like a battered wife
that's about it Jesus Christ it looks
like you're folding one of those paper
claws and the fact of third grade does
he like me
Apple says go screw yourself notice like
the left like I'm just watching this
coverage the left gets really pissed
around Christmastime that's a good point
I kind of get it like like so wait so
wait a minute a bearded red fat guy
breaks into your house and gives you
property but like I'm pretty sure Santa
was invented to keep Bernie Sanders up
at night
yes but then Jane sender said I'll take
that and put it into a slush fund say
don't be always became supposed to do me
a Bernie Grinch two years ago that's
true we almost had a Bernie grace two
years ago it'll work I don't know if I
don't know how often he watched the snow
did you know that I was on Bernie
Sanders is flight when we went when we
went to Burlington he was on my flight
God in heaven tell me there's a story
well here's the problem
I felt so bad in real life he's so frail
he can barely move so here's the true
story
not gay Jarrod was there it was like
first off my wife makes a mistake we're
at the Washington DC and WA was Reagan
Dulles I think so Airport and she sees
Bernie Sanders and so she yells out to
me and I try and keep a low profile and
I get recognized every now and then and
she goes steven crowder I'm like oh my
god
my tickets been punched and I'm sitting
on you outside of five guys at the
airport buzz if she goes Steven I go
geez geez and we got into a fight about
it we got over really quickly but it was
a fight like it was one of those like I
can't believe you tell you wanna die so
she goes Bernie Sanders is right there
and it was always like a Wes Anderson
film there's a wish pan and you're just
standing there you know it's like kind
of 80 hands and he didn't even have a
briefcase so you know he didn't know
work because he was about to fly back to
Burlington he was two roads ahead of me
okay he was in the economy plus plus
right on a dividing line of first class
and you know that was a point of pride
for him like he got every perk from
first class except a cocktail right he
had all the legroom a more I'm among the
people so what's so funny and I swear to
you I have pictures of this when it is
combined toes are digging in
millionaires the person insanity at this
point I've been up for like 16 hours
I've worked a 14-hour day and gotten
onto a flight and I was so tired and
like I have to do something I like tweet
them in like got if you don't do
something you're gonna regret this for
the rest of your life
so I'm looking at him and he's on his
iPad and I could tell it was the iPad
pro I could tell by the bezel that it
was a new 10.5 so he's not hurting for
cash mr. hoarder cat crazy crazy got it
so he's sitting there and every now and
then when they're bringing something
free in first class I swear to you I
could see him I said like cocktails
really any big mmm-hmm and he'd go back
down
go in psalm i go into the restroom and I
change into my socialism's for figs
shirt this was a challenge alone at your
size in an airplane yes very difficult
pretty sure I contracted something I
didn't want to do this by the way was
the day after the Ted Cruz Bernie debate
the one where he just was Lordan even
the even the Young Turks look who's
gonna kill Ted Cruz and then in the
middle of that they're like oh my god
then Bernie was sitting there like you
never got me down then they just got
knocked out and level there you go so
that's how bad it was so I put on the
social dance for Figg shirt of course he
gets boarding off the plane first cuz
economy plus plus plus and we get off
and everyone's going one direction and
we're in Burlington and he goes down
this hallway and I swear to you it was
like it might as well have been a
painting called lonely sad man because
he's walking with his Rain Man jacket
and no briefcase and like just barely
hobbling down this hallway it must have
taken him 50 minutes or walked in the
hallway I just looked at him and I
looked at my wife I said I can't I can't
it's 1:00 o'clock in the morning is like
George Lucas in the food court
[Laughter]
hey hey George you've ruined Indiana
Jones but then you feel bad for him
because he's fat and lonely and has
fortunes yes exactly I mean if you were
Kim Jong and one gigantic mono chin he's
like he's like the chicks from reboot
with the one boob that goes across oh my
gosh I can't you guys Reba look are you
Canadian no Canadian thing did you talk
about yeah but if that's what the
socialist Muppet was doing what was the
puppeteer doing that's Mike yes exactly
I have no idea what someone had his
thumb up his ass that's the main
takeaway yeah and actually that's not
fair not even elmo is that red no no no
but the puppeteer is and everyone
watched that documentary you know Elmo
VMO puppeteers a pedophile right oh yeah
did you know that I did I can tell
you're tired until not get yours dish
yeah you didn't know this man he was
splintered though now the Ninja Turtles
are ruined yeah yes put your doing Tai
Chi in the cage you can't even
no everyone watched that documentary
being Elmo or becoming Elmo and then it
turned out that he was actually like he
was really just a sick sick twisted
person so you watch it you're like oh my
gosh she's so look at him he just wants
to be a kid like no he just wants to be
in kids and then you realize that he's
really sick and twisted and it ruined
everything I think he's an I think he's
doing time well I hope he's doing time
yeah I would hope so yeah he's like
Harvey Weinstein robot times a million
because they were children him and
Mohammed yeah all right sorry Razorfish
how'd it turns uh it kind of turns
Tickle Me Elmo into more of a porn what
are we doing no he did like that semi
[ __ ] on CNN I can just hear the people
tuning out so what is I've we're at our
15 here's the thing I keep looking to
the screen here there is nothing on CNN
nothing you know all day there's been
nothing the only real newsworthy thing I
don't know to you to me the most
newsworthy thing all day of course was
the Muslim the Afghani Muslim who ran a
van into Christmas shoppers and said he
did it because of the mistreatment of
Muslims yeah feels like yesterday we've
heard about that we all have to wait
until an Tifa derails the Polar Express
yeah tell makes me sing his hot
chocolate and they just stabbed with an
ice pick hot hot hot oh damn this campus
police oh yeah we're swastika and that
little kid who looks like Michael
Douglas from falling down with the
glasses and the buzz cut don't think we
didn't notice what was happening there
okay Tim crutch razor fist what else
though 2017 whole year you have to pick
your favorite moment all year long
politically culturally like is there one
is there something really sticks out you
know it's gotta be it's gotta be Donna
Brazile dedicating her book to set rich
Betty a new and exciting level of troll
I'm sorry like that's gonna be hard to
top that is true I'm ever in that and
then and the right started embracing
Donna Brazile and I'm gonna like you
know this woman is no doubt was off and
then she went on the view and of course
she was like now I hate Republicans like
well there you go and then that ended
really quickly right that's a gun I
forgot she dedicated her book to seth
rich and you know she probably played a
part in killing the guy yes that's one
thing like i'm not a conspiracy theorist
okay we'll leave you this because we do
have to get going we have Pogo and then
Dean Cain then we have to wrap up a
YouTube Carol well we get to see if tiny
not gay Jerrod survives from the AIDS he
was down to his last 200 cd4 cells um
let me ask you this when it comes to
Donna Brazile i don't entertain
conspiracy theories okay right but and I
know you're more of a libertarians or
not on the crazy conspiracy sort of a
front line I'm not gonna start talking
like Jesse Ventura
I don't know if that's just even sure if
that's generous but if you have to bet
gun your head okay everyone in this room
including spend computer all right gun
to your head razor fist
do you think the Clintons have played a
role in killing somebody I I think it's
keep in mind the Underwood's were based
on them did you
III think you'd be a back in Arkansas
yes okay thank the body that was moved
in the head by the way have did you ever
watch Norm Macdonald troll the girls on
the view about that I you know what it's
been wiped clean off of youtube yeah
Angie here Bill Clinton I killed the guy
you can't be my favorite court merely
looks to start Jones you guys yeah and I
never watched our Wars but you know I
know
tell you really liked it yeah Billy Dee
Williams you know I'm talking about okay
so you do think Arkansas probably at
least they knew about it yeah okay
that's macoraba day by a Huckabee kind
of it's been corroborated comedy okay
what do you think of the Clintons have
that have played a role
absolutely 100 percent yes I don't even
know what the thought process is here
the answer is yes
okay absolutely no doubt do you all
think that animam and a bare minimum he
killed innocent civilians when he shot
tomahawk missiles at Afghanistan and
wound up killing like houses full and
it's Indiana everything I'm talking like
political game here on US soil yes he
did
yes they did they played a part they
made the call something like that yes
and you also believe that next she also
believed that george w bush was next to
tower seven with an ACME plunger the
rams hopefully not all right that's been
computer do you think if you have to bet
your life on it okay so use it to bet
your life yes or no the Clintons Bill
and Hillary Clinton have they knowingly
played a role or knew about the murder
of someone do you think so what people
didn't know about a murder from know
about it or play ok but you only they
played a role in it no I got a full [ __ ]
computer and say no they didn't kill any
you want to work directly involved okay
all right okay so spends the other voice
knock a Jared no okay so not just Milan
it's the only conspiracy theory or if
you read up on if you read up on Vince
Foster if you read up on Brown you're
like and I'm again there's very little
else that I was like what do we know
about yeah I know I know I know I mean
there's nothing they wouldn't do know
right okay okay well there we go we won
one everyone says yes and one cybernetic
organism says no razor fits with a zero
where's the best place for people to
find you brother well you can you can
find me on my youtube channel which is
youtube.com slash C / the range of Halle
we'll just have to go through the web
Time Machine and look back and go oh
those were the days all right Reggie
fist thank you so much since we won't
see you before and have a Merry
Christmas and a Happy New Year and we'll
see you in the new year without a doubt
sir Godspeed thanks for having me on
leptin all right thank you take care go
back with your appendix compendex
hearing a Blackhawk Cuban at you how big
a Blackhawk is it oh no well they get
crystal on its bill kristol
feel like it's like it's blackboard oh
no it's blackboard they put out a tweet
that dictionary.com put out that there's
a word for somebody who praises someone
every 12 seconds but they didn't tell us
what the word was but dictionary calms
getting in on the action come on one
thing about Bill
bill kristol is just such a wiener a
little bit like that the thing about
Bill Kristol
it's not that he was a never Trumper
like I didn't even disagree with him on
everything but it's just Bill Kristol is
everything that people don't like about
Republicans yeah okay let's hear what
Bill Kristol has to say smelling his own
farts enjoy I thought Hopper lovely
tries to sleep there you're the Vice
President or Secretary of State or
you're a cabinet member and you behave
with dignity and appropriate deference
to the president but there's a kind of
third world Banana Republic quality to
the way Pence's here's the problem bill
kristol we just listen to him for 45
seconds and you said nothing and that's
the problem with cable news they're
taught and by the way this is something
I'll let you in a little I've talked
about this before a little inside
baseball it's an actual technique people
will not a technique but it's it's sort
of a I guess you would say an approach
that they're taught from their think
tanks from their consulting firms most
of these people they don't make their
living off of cable news that pays
pathetically so they work for think-tank
so they're consultants for four
political insiders to some degree and
they also make some cash on the side if
did Johnny Mathis oh my gosh he is not
aged well
so what happens is they're taught to
take up as much time as possible because
if you're in a quadrant or you're in a
split three screen right you're going
okay there's only so much time we have
an eight-minute segment take up as much
time as possible so you're not taught to
make your points as succinctly and
effectively as possible you're taught to
try and cut off the ring to try and keep
the other guy from talking for a certain
amount of time and so Bill Kristol is
trained he's conditioned to use as much
time while saying as little as possible
right and they wrap it up with a point
at the end it was like they're it's like
he his heart set on being a professional
career congressional filibuster and then
just like took like the second best just
CNN settled yeah well he will he's a
national he's National Review still yeah
I believe so it's kind of like leaning
on a guy on the cage and running out the
clock in MMA
right right and just kind of waiting for
the time to go all right that's fine
computer has some more signups know the
way so bye thanks so much for people
we're in the homestretch here we have
segment five Howard second of five of
yeah you might realize with Dean Cain
and we won't be able to play the whole
thing I'll just play segment five we'll
have time to play the whole Christmas
Carol thing people count on it no people
weren't care they've seen it they've
already seen people been watching the
whole day look okay let's ask spend
computer spend computer a lot of Thunder
that comes to us Michael we've had a lot
of signups here today and so we're going
to read some aloud right every news
month with members by the way we will
figure out by next week because renewals
start in January a lot of people have
been saying what if I renew for three
years do I get a special gift it never
even occurred to me because online
people usually don't pay for things they
find a way to steal it our fans have
been so loyal yeah thank you so much if
you sign up for three years we will find
something really really cool to give you
we just haven't even thought of it so we
will provide you with that option for
people who join them you're up for
renewal a lot of people are up for
renewal January 1st thank you for asking
spend computer tell us about the new
signups well we have a bunch of new
people who send screenshots so first one
is Joshua thank you very much Joshua we
have Noah Noah see there's a biblical
may only have a Patrick the coeliac make
sure no a personal info is revealed to
an account okay Joseph Ward shots the
set Charl what's that Wesley temples hey
Wesley palsy don't get nicks on tax
evasion like Snipes oh no that's the
last name you said it's like scrotum
Benjamin scrotum well you know what I'm
sorry
grade school was horrible for you but
now you're a part of the club that
matters more even thank you whoo Thank
You Steven Steven now let's eat them I
said these it Ethan like you who's Ethan
here no yeah deprived maybe there you go
baby
that's like you feisty German come on I
like Stevens thank you very much I can't
hear you I said okay
it's subordinate you by Nazi computer
I've ever seen okay continue then we
have Tony thank you very much Tony
Tomi's great caught Wow really
ha God there we go shock shock and then
the last one I think it's just that oh
yeah that's just that you're steamed
that every time you join mug Club
Mohammed gets to do a shot and angel
gets his wings
obviously our influence and angel gets
these wings and of course mama doesn't
get to witness it because he's burning
in hell yes he's first neck edge here
and support with you always
otherwise that that usually is an easy
laugh from him it's true if ever I need
an easy laugh from Jared if that or the
crazy asian voice yes yeah
alright listen we are coming we're going
into the homestretch
you know listen I had people out there
say no people told me don't do the whole
Christmas Carol bit at the end because
they've been watching people have been
watching for the whole day and it's like
that's like 40 minutes is it really that
30 mins 30 mins well I've had a lot of
people say janta biscuit is there a way
for us to get that out to them on all
right let's put out a poll let's put out
a poll who want we've had four segments
thus far we have a final segment for a
YouTube Carol right and the final
segment of of YouTube Carol and people
are wanting to know ok listen do you
want us to run segment one through four
and five as one continuous film or just
segment five most people were telling me
they just wanted to watch segment 5
because they've been watching all day
okay so maybe we play segment 5 and then
give people the opportunity will you be
able to upload it for them to watch yeah
yeah we just don't want out we don't I
don't want to waste your time if it's
the segment or two like myself and we'd
love to see it all but maybe not tonight
hey it's the brawny man hey oh ho no one
can see him it's Aaron the intern he's
wearing plaid like the brawny man there
you go and he's wearing no socks did
your Hey is he still dry find out to my
wife give did this [ __ ] keep this it's
not a [ __ ]
it's a dwarf the dwarf keep the socks I
think the dwarf kept the socks oh you
know we can't we can't run the whole
thing because we have two guests we have
Dean Cain and poco 10:30 so just do the
segment
just a segment that's all we can upload
it later for everybody watch there you
go we have Pogo coming up and not too
long and then we also have of course Oh
hold on a second what is this someone
has said wait stop what are you saying a
second computer beep that was just for
calling they did not put out the poll
okay okay all right nice
no Courtney she's helping with Twitter
we're only running segment five of a
YouTube Carol the conclusion narrated by
mark repeat oh and the conclusion the
finale will take place at the very end
of this program okay let's bring back up
CNN again former CIA detector again John
O Brennan it's a tweet from John O
Brennan
on Donald Trump's reaction to the UN's
reaction to Donald Trump
recognizing Jerusalem as the capital of
Israel he claims he's making tool in the
bench you notice how they cover up the
time stamp of the Twitter do you notice
that not gauge Aaron yeah take care of
the time stamp because it's like it
happened at 1:15 or something else he
says he demands blind loyalty no he says
his actions demand blind loyalty that's
not true he said loyalty he asked for
Logan this wasn't about that his
decision on Jerusalem is what he's
talking about right no no this is from
coming from a long time ago that tweet
was not the tweet was about Jerusalem
that he just brought up well here's the
deal is Donald Trump the county high
ORAC sector like listed you better be
loyal to be in everything or us or
disagree against the wall probably did
that happen here no no even Ben Shapiro
we all agreed listen I don't know am I
the only one who thinks like nothing
that Donald Trump has done regarding
Israel is if anything outside the basic
realms of reason no let's look at what
he's done
okay he's only talking because the Sony
presence before I said it precedence of
being complete [ __ ] has a red nose he
does do i yeah you do are you okay can
you handle the rest of the evening no
think about it for a second I'm gonna be
the only son why did Donald Trump do
okay he said all right Jerusalem is a
capital of Israel well it has been
always and they said we're going to
recognize it we're gonna put our embassy
there right there was a bill sign that
we're suppose to happen
every president said they were going to
do it so that's his big offense right so
that's that's the sin that Donald Trump
committed the UN men voted what did the
UN vote to do nothing they voted to
condemn Donald Trump in this
administration that's it it's a vote to
publicly humiliate Donald Trump okay so
that's step two Donald Trump did with
every other president had has said they
would do he's the first one to actually
do it oh my wife is calling out huh all
right come on up or you can go go with
mom oh I know you like Gerald so that's
number one number two number three is my
wife got me to lose my concentration
here you're talking so that's it so the
UN is said we're gonna vote to condemn
Donald Trump then it passed
overwhelmingly because the UN is a bunch
of horrible he goes in there and says
exactly what you say screw you all right
exactly so now we're at step number
three and what is step number three oh
this is why we're sitting back in the
bush opera come here buddy who's like I
was so comfortable oh my gosh he is a
prop what about if anybody else gets a
seizure they don't they don't let dogs
have guns sorry sorry so now we're
talking about Donald Trump did what all
presidents said they were going to do
now we're talking about the UN's mad
about it
yeah and Trump said we'll screw you and
now we're talking about a tweet about
Donald Trump screw you to the UN this is
all day the Rotarians move saying that
he's taking names are you kidding me I
don't understand this I do understand
how this is a network please everybody
if you've learned nothing today and if
you're still alive and you can hear this
something else I think it's really
important this kind of journalistic
malpractice is not bread just in one
year since then this has been going on
for a long time I don't think there have
ever been the journalistic standards of
integrity that people think there have
been outside of the the movies I really
don't yeah again it goes back to the
selfish nature liberal
believe that everyone's selfish and
everyone's bad except for when it comes
to the government all of a sudden you
give all the money to Nancy Pelosi and
it's gonna be smooth sailing right for
some reason they want to believe that
everyone's bad and everyone's selfish
when it comes to corporations when it
comes to businesses when it comes to the
guy who's running a local Arby's or
running a local Quiznos we want to
believe this guy needs to be taxed out
the wazoo he shouldn't be able to pass
his real estate on to his children
because it's a horrible human being when
it comes to multinational multi-billion
dollar news corporations however like
CNN or MSNBC Fox News not withstanding
we're supposed to believe that they have
standards ready because George Clooney
made a movie once I mean this has been
happening forever that's the thing I I
mean this doesn't occur overnight it dis
occurs over decades and decades of no
one calling them on it I find myself a
little like like Steve Martin and planes
trains and automobiles like this would
all be just it all would be tolerable if
it they weren't so boring this is so
boring
talk about something oh my gosh I don't
know how people do this yeah there's
someone who lives down the street I can
see because they have it they have a
bunch of windows I can see that FoxNews
on 24/7 and then there's someone else
and I can do they have seen you in on
all day I can't do that I don't know how
you live with that but you also seen
this coming to write you it's been
happening over decades but look over the
last eight years before Trump came into
office and it was singing the praises of
Barack Obama no matter what he did right
Ram stuff I grew on health care oh he's
the best president ever completely
privatized what is a base of our economy
there you go we got a guest come on
privatize the economy oh that's no
problem at all I mean they think about
it they didn't start to really turn on
him any until Hillary started to
separate herself from him in the race
right that's when they started to go
with Hillary but not against Obama on
their own but because Hillary was kind
of trying to separate herself well this
is what we what we said on air early on
today it's not about the standards that
are applied yeah it's about whether they
are applied equally and are they
applying the same filter to this
administration well the Bush
administration as they did to Barack
Obama and that's where you know if their
interest lies in either if they have a
vested interest in getting someone
elected keeping them in office or if
they have a vested interest in the truth
it's about how they apply their
criticism right
if they apply their standards equally
and if you look at CNN today here's the
thing we take we took one day now this
is more of a snapshot than most people
get at 15 you know 15 minutes in an
airport granted but we took one day
today I would bet you that you couldn't
find one single day ever in the history
of CNN throughout the eight years of the
Obama presidency that was this critical
and negative I don't think you could
find one day he could have gotten
outside and pissed on the lawn wave to
the cameras and walk back in and it
would have been too bad that's true
I mean sure he could have I mean think
about it he would have walked out
pissing the lawn wave to the camera
never have said Wow can you look at the
fire hose on that president so the
rumors are true
that's what they would have done I just
I you know I didn't have any trust in
media beforehand but this is solidified
it and like I said what I do what we do
with our show is when we go into the
morning pitch most of our sources come
from the look he's trying to get rid of
us come on operate on take that off tell
them to take it off we get most of our
sources from the left when you say knock
a Jared I would say probably 80% 80% of
our sources but I have everyone on the
team bookmark liberal sites and then
conservative sites so you've got two
rows and like I said with when I get up
and I have news in the morning
I've got NPR I've got Reuters I've got
Fox News I listen to them side by side
so I know what both people are saying
and I can tell you today exactly what
they're saying Donald Trump has decided
to finally recognize Jerusalem as the
capital of Israel and station the
embassy there after the vote in 1995
passed 390 something to since whatever
was a binding agreement guaranteeing
that the embassy would be in Jerusalem
no later than May 1999 and of course
Hamas is upset then you go to PBS or you
go to NPR and it says Donald Trump is
killing Palestinians all right our next
guest look he I don't know what time it
is over there but he's calling us from
the land down under every bump outside
of our intro track which maybe will
change him to maybe he'll make a custom
intro track for us but we do have a
custom is hurting somebody else at all
but every other bump that we use on the
show is from this guy I probably listen
to him more than any artist I have
discovered in the last 10 years you know
him you love him he's a good-looking
chap
nomás pogo poke nic bert keepo gooo Pogo
thank you so much for being here sir
Steve how you guys doing good so Wilson
D God's voice again how's it going
horribly 16 hours well no we've enough
for much longer but we've been doing the
seat watching CNN for 15 hours 15 hours
yeah God all right listen I hate to do
this but I'm have to give you the hit
list of CNN for the day okay okay I'm
gonna try and rapid-fire this so just to
kind of the whole purpose of this was to
see how biased CNN is and you can only
know by watching an entire day of the
original programming by the way they're
lazy it's only 16 hours they don't do 24
hours of programming it's a bunch of
diabetes reboxetine hours generous
yeah 16 hours is generous could because
they've been running the same 15 minutes
so they start off with Russia probe
Russia probe Russia probe molar Adam
Schiff talked about the molar probe he's
been singing as evidence for nine months
no evidence no mention not once of
uranium one and I know your social media
savvy so that was number one trend on
Twitter and Facebook all day they've
been saying that 9 million Tiny Tim's
will die because Republicans want to do
with a hide health care initiative which
is not true no mention of the male born
attacker by the way being Afghani seed
nori who said that he was doing it for
the mistreatment of Muslims not one
mention all day on CNN it's never been
mentioned they just said some guy ran a
van into holiday shoppers holiday not
Christmas that's the the cherry on top
of the politically correct crap Sunday
then they talked about Israel there's no
mention of the 1995 Israel vote of
course which said of course Jerusalem is
the capital of Israel and of course our
embassy should be there
they said that ban in breaking news
Bannon hates bush when Bannon actually
said this in June and then finally when
we realized that Republicans actually
wanted to extend its spending what
October October sorry when we realized
that Republicans actually said listen we
don't wanna shut the government down
let's let's create the sign this bill
here so we can kick it to January 19th
they were saying Tiny Tim was gonna die
then they realize it wasn't they just
said ah 45 seconds of devoted house
decided to kick this down the road no
recognition that Republicans foot it
forward finally apparently it's a
problem that Mike Pence the vice
president is supporting the president
that was breaking news for about four
hours there you go that's the entire CNN
news cycle for today Nick any thought
well the last thing I knew the last
thing I heard of CNN is you guys had
some kind of platform insert into New
York and the only thing CNN wanted to
cover
during the the whole escapade was the
alleged allegation that Trump drinks 12
drinks every day or something like that
diet coke yeah yeah and you're thinking
like why is there attention on this guy
like if you don't like somebody you
probably shouldn't make every move of
theirs you know breaking that breaking
news headline let me see this Melbourne
obviously that's that's in your home
country here how much do you know about
this attack now is do people in
Australia know that it was seen nior Ian
that he said you know listen this is
because of mistreatment of Muslims or is
that kind of common knowledge it's news
to me at the moment Steve sorry yeah
really well he also said like he also
said that his toaster was talking to him
but like Sven computer said that's kind
of hedging your bets it's like so ya
know Muslim Afghani might as well like
Russian Roulette with a single stack yes
Russian Roulette with a single stack I
mean it is it is great you know what
that tells me that the Australian News
is doing a disservice as well because
you have to go searching for this stuff
it's hard to find the real information
out then do you guys have a 24-hour news
station in Australia no I think so I
think everyone packs up around 7:00 all
right I know my lady innopolis I spoke
to Parliament not long ago which was
mind-blowing I don't know if that if if
such a thing would be allowed to happen
in the US what do you think about that
what did he speak to Parliament about oh
jeez everything just warning everyone
about the bias of the left-wing
journalists you know double-check
everything you know think for yourself
don't just buy into the into the into
the narratives on the TV just yeah I was
really impressed that we even allowed
him to speak in Bamiyan boiling away
honestly I'm surprised they allowed that
to that's I mean listen if they allow
anyone to speak and actually kind of
coach them from the private sector from
outside their government bubble I'm
happy about it so that surprised me no I
don't think I would be allowed here in
the United States you probably allowed
to be a lobbyist and go have coffee with
them or something like that I'm not
entirely sure let me ask a let me ask
you this Nick so you're a creative type
but what is your favorite political /
cultural moment of 2017 we've been
asking everyone if you have to pick a
moment from 2017 what would you say is
your highlight kind of as far as news or
culture anything like that it would have
to be the
let's protesting of Donald Trump's
election by encouraging everyone across
the nation to scream into the sky for
half an hour
that's that was of that okay you know
what that's true that was 2017 a lot of
other people said election night but the
inauguration that was the lady ah
screaming in her green jacket yeah that
was that was early on in a year well
that's kind of sad because that means
that what the highlight of your year was
last January nothing else was the
anniversary well no no I mean to your
favorite moment all year but that was a
good moment yeah Alma all year of 2017
you can pick any but that was a good one
I'm wondering if there's there's any
other moment that that might stick out
to me this last week has been pretty
incredible honestly mm-hmm watching
what's been going on what what have you
guys been covering I know you've been
doing your I'm changed my mind series
which I love I think everyone is really
getting on board with that too oh gosh
well thank you so much you know it's
funny that you mentioned that because we
had carolers come in so you know we were
doing a lot this we had [ __ ] dwarf
Jesus and dwarf Santa wrestle and figgy
pudding to determine the true spirit of
Christmas right here in the studio and
we also had carolers come in yeah by the
way Jesus won so that's the true spirit
of Christmas thank God and we had
carolers come in well this was a
surprise knock cage I did this for me
and the carolers came in there were
three carolers it turns out there are
four carolers but one of them saw me on
the green-screen monitor started sobbing
uncontrollably
and said she wouldn't come in and sing
for me and she left she had to be
carried out because she couldn't walk
out on her own strength that she didn't
want to participate in our program so
she didn't to refute sting she's been
the main topic of like the last ten
hours I know she doesn't I'm gonna track
her down but what's funny is because you
mention to change my mind so our
producer said hey listen how much do you
know about the show he said listen and
she she locked herself in my green room
locking us out by the way there are many
guns in the green room so she was
probably just more trigger we have a
revolver a classic revolver on display
so um then my producer says listen you
can just you can go if you disagree with
him what you can actually go in and talk
to him right here sit next time on the
recliner and he'll listen is she just
freaked out and left she was like the
Wicked Witch of the West melting into
the floor
she was that hysterical wow that's crazy
what made you guys want to do the whole
change my mind series what what was the
starting moment for that we were talking
about that I was in a pitch meeting and
I just sitting there going like it was
something really basic or it's good okay
is it me maybe there's something on
missing and I said you know listen me
I'm open to having my mind change and I
realized I can't have my mind change by
Sally cone or Christopher Titus or the
Liberals who come on the show you know
from TechCrunch who are coming on with
their sword ready right for attacks I
said but you know what let's just go to
a college or let's go somewhere where
some people who are moderately
complicated said maybe go to Planned
Parenthood with I am pro-life changed my
mind yeah they kicked us out boy but so
that was like let's go to someone who's
moderately educated and I said and I'm
moving to bite my tongue use the
Socratic method and just see if people
can rationalize their position it was
the opposite of cable news it started
with me saying maybe have a blind spot
and that's we're honestly blown away
blown away that it's been as successful
as it is because it's the opposite of
this they have you know nine minutes to
do a segment and then six minutes of
commercials and they all have to hit
their talking points and try and block
time for the other guy and it's at we
just said let's do the opposite that was
the inspiration yeah and people have
been pretty civil so for the most part
pretty simple wouldn't you say well we
have one coming up it's pro-life later
where a girl tried to steal my
microphone and then told me that I had
no right to take it back
I don't like but that's my microphone so
you know yes all that yes well there's
it gets worse and the lady you said I
was scum most of the time it's pretty
civil you do realize that when you get
on college campus a lot of these kids
I mean they've just been they've been
raised in a generation where they're
just taught they can take anything they
want and and if and if someone else
throw tests they're the oppressor so we
literally sit them down with a table and
and ask them questions and do the change
my mind and we've tried to be civil and
then there one girl took the microphone
and say hey that's my microphone I want
it back
she freaked out and you just realize
that's a generation of people who've
been told like well if you want the
microphone it's now your microphone you
realize it's not its generation well who
the crazy liberal ones it's like a dog
on a choker chain that you've been just
pulling on the tension just in just the
media yeah during the pot real attention
so you have the opportunity steven
crowder and shared they just you get a
couple in there
you can tell it's been waiting for that
moment right the bite yet but the people
who weren't eaten enough his children
right exactly exactly but you know what
I will say what gave me hope is there
was a girl when we were SMU in an Obama
shirt
she had an Obama Oh eight shirt and when
this this other girl who took the
microphone started doing her freak out
deal this girl in the Obama
oh wait shirt black girl actually I saw
her do this out of the corner of my eye
like oh these are our representatives on
campus so even there I think there's
it's just they scream the loudest but I
don't think most people agree with them
anymore no that's a small bubble isn't
it it's a small bubble but CN n is that
bubble that's what so it's amplified
because all of CN n is that bubble all
of the entertainment industry is that
bubble but in real life it's this tiny
bubble you have to search for but if you
flip on the TV whether it's
entertainment or media it's everything
and that's where I think the disconnect
is that's why most people think America
is this crazy leftist place but it's not
when they visit you know it's not what
you see on TV these news entities or
entertainment outlets aren't vitriolic
enough on their own it's kind of the
concoction the magic potion that comes
together to create these social just
worries who freaked out about everything
you know crying Trump girl and stuff
yeah
you know combine all these things
together you know powers unites then you
got some real really weird [ __ ] well
what about Australia
Pogo oh go ahead star you're gonna ask
me something I was just gonna ask you do
you think Twitter and Facebook is
helping to change the direction of that
pendulum do you think more and more
people are starting to question the
media or do you think it's very much the
way it's always been
no I here's the thing well you know most
people don't watch CNN unfortunately and
this was a thing with net neutrality
that I just found so funny all of these
youtubers fell in line and said we're we
need net neutrality we can't repeal it
the Obama 2015 rules look Comcast and
Verizon want to repeal it I'm gonna on a
second the biggest supporters of net
neutrality are Google YouTube Facebook
Twitter Apple who just started slowing
down phones so for some reason when it
came to the net neutrality debate it's a
good example people were selectively
outraged with corporations yeah AT&T is
bad for Rison is bad the local
mom-and-pop ISP in Missouri is bad but
YouTube and Google and Facebook and
Apple are inherently altruistic and now
we see a
couldn't care less about being fair
they're slowing down your phone not
because of data but because it's old
they want you to buy a new one and so I
think you're seeing yeah you're seeing
this happen right now into a degree
that's just I just think people are so
blinded by it but unfortunate so you see
Facebook now saying we're going to just
no longer flag fake news we're not going
to show it all together but we've been
watching 16 hours of fake news all day
so CNN gets the right of way on Facebook
because Zuckerberg and Zucker are
buddies and we get throttled so
unfortunately I think social media
provided that opportunity but you see
what the the Twitter purged and you see
with what YouTube is trying to do is
they're trying to they're trying to
create this alliance with old media old
media is dying but they have some
dollars and they're amidst their death
throes but let me see in Australia what
do you think in Australia do you think
it's a bubble that's amplified by the
media do you think most people are
actually pretty reasonable do you think
it's just as crazy as we see in your
media cuz when I watch Australian
morning TV I'm like oh my god this seems
like this seems crazy it's gone so far
on the bend look the TV makes it much
worse than it than it actually is yeah I
thought one of the things I love about
culture in Australia is that everyone
gets a fair go everyone gets a you know
the megaphone no one's head gets higher
than anyone else's head right and it's
actually is something I think is quite
different about Australia everyone's on
the same playing field so people call it
tall poppy syndrome which is this
phenomenon in which like achievement is
not really a welcome for celebration
it's actually kind of treated with
almost completely complete indifference
but the other side of that coin is
everyone gets the same you know the same
treatment so I know Milo did an
appearance on some morning TV show here
and they he absolutely annihilated this
feminist who was on there this half-ball
feminist he called it and just destroy
it and I think a lot of Australians kind
of agree with that
it's getting out and people are being
spoon-fed and distracted instead of
thinking for themselves yeah I can
imagine I mean look we have this we have
the other attack today in Melbourne and
I mean what do you get down to van
control you guys had the mandatory gun
buyback you know what do you do people
have access to cars people can hurt and
we've been told the reason I say this is
because in the United States Australia
has been used as the example for gun
control you know Obama use them Pelosi
use them seeing
has used them I think maybe even today
saying look at the gun buyback in
Australia how successful it's been well
it really hasn't crime violent crime and
actually murder hasn't really been
changed but people can also kill people
with cars you know you give them a Land
Rover you give them a Chevrolet Tahoe
it's a lot it's a lot worse than a
mishap with my little Walther here at a
certain point as a weapon rightly you
can't nerf the whole world and you know
I wonder if people are coming to that
realization and we're seeing that with
the UK in Australia I hate that you guys
have to be a cautionary tale but I will
say to the United States you're kind of
becoming that just because the left is
pointed to you guys for so long saying
look it works perfectly here and now
that was then maybe not mmm yeah look
it's kind of a welfare country you guys
have over over there right and we have
over over here too and we're starting to
place all sorts of taxes on the other
fares and actually on the on the side of
the passenger now as well because they
filled it all you know it's it's all the
incomes being taken out of the country
it's it's it's an offshore organization
we're losing that cash we need to tax
this we'd have to tax that and so you
know now the little guys paying the
price as usual right exactly that
happened in Montreal they allowed uber
what was it the the uber drivers tell us
they allowed uber then they started
taxing them out of existence and then
they said okay we will allow you but it
became so expensive that it almost
became unusable yeah and think about it
that's one thing is is there is there
anything more ironic to you than
socialists being against what they have
coined the sharing economy yeah yeah
yeah I think it's a government's job to
regulate a free-market I'm sorry I don't
think that's their business yeah
especially when the quality is so much
better
uber is a much more pleasant experience
in taxis just like Airbnb it's lovely
yes absolutely the home team for the
government that's true big unions will
always be a home team for the government
I hope you guys could get uber what
about lyft is lift allowed or same same
Bo haven't heard of this no what's
what's lift well it's like competition
to uber that makes it better because
they're nipping at their heels so yeah
it makes sense that you guys don't have
lyft I'm sorry hey let me ask you what's
coming up from pogo what can we expect
what should we be looking for as far as
albums and when
we going to get a custom louder with
Crowder song there we go people were
asking but not yeah that's a really good
idea
well I'm busy trying to carve some space
in the schedule at the moment to do
something for you guys because I just
especially with your whole changed my
mind series you guys are really onto
something with that and that's inspiring
me but at the moment I'm trying to get
my next album out for the next for the
new year I'm gay awkward made at the
moment with with a my one of my really
good friends there'll be a lot of
SoundCloud releases in there but a lot
of new stuff as well so hopefully in the
next couple of weeks we'll see ok well
absolutely listen if you do get
something done
I've changed my mind is what's inspiring
you we will change the montage song
we're using a poco song well change it
to a custom song we can switch out all
YouTube videos if it's just the musical
track actually I think it's partners
yeah I love it that sounds awesome so
yeah we love you over here and all of
our fans constantly ask us where is this
company what is this music can we say
pogo pogo pogo go go download it listen
we have to go we have Dean Cain coming
up on the final installment of a youtube
carol nick where's the best place for
people to find you
youtube.com forward slash Pogo is the
best place to find me that's the best
thank you so much for stopping by we
appreciate it and listen have a Merry
Christmas and a Happy New Year because
we probably talked to you before then
thank you so much sir thanks guys all
right guys thank you Merry Christmas and
God bless we are in the homestretch
let's turn up CNN to see if anything
here has happened it says new
developments new development design
president Trump set to sign the tax cut
bill tomorrow do you mean the bill that
he helped design it's like it's like
saying new developments Stephens going
to put a period at the end of the tweet
that he's already composed use
punctuation in tweets by the way that's
a woman though right yeah the one the
one next to over Clay Aiken of CNN
contributors it look like Buffalo Bill I
don't really know what Buffalo Bill
looks like but I got the bill sounds of
the Lambs oh damn it sorry
I'd say the chair but he's working on a
technical difficulty thing yeah
I don't listen you want to tell me that
this this is a panel of healthy-looking
people
less is too far thank you
Evan ease our YouTube awakened to find
himself in a familiar place yes it was
so the bed was his own the curtains were
his own the room was his own kiddies a
schoolboy okay way okay
merry Christmas everyone
Oh merciful heavens I will make things
right I shall make amends all three
spirits of YouTube now live within me
are saved on my knees I was sitting
logistics on my knees okay
give up on fellow what dice tonight me
what day is today
you don't know what there is was that
Christmas Day pal it's Christmas Day I
haven't missed it
the spirits did it all in one night
course it's remarkable young man
I'm glad do you know that our Mac
hanging in the Apple store window we
know bloody hero that's as big as me
best one an intelligent remarkable young
good go and fetch it for me bring it to
the Cratchit house and I'll give you
shilling
that's all but things are like those in
quite breaches ammunition Tetley minutes
I'll give you half the crap that's right
even clothes do that I've no money
look at me I'm a wee lad have a tiny
bearded boy with no money lovely learn
to row me halt
throw me a credit card have blind trust
and hope I come back that's all you got
me a bit you tuition right I'll do it
but just to be on the total off without
me I'm gonna get myself something
without who's that gonna get well no
it's any of your business but here's the
deal I'm gonna get me a blue cheese
keeper
I've only only Magic Trackpad like
keyboard a magic trick pendant on your
wife ok I'm all the way I'll be writing
about no idea I'm gonna carry a
remarkable
[Music]
Oh mr. YouTube you sure
Shankar Krejci well not at work today
mr. YouTube is Christmas Day
you see vet as a fit excuse to rob me of
my sir but I mean no sir but you said I
could have the day off I'll crush it I
won't stand for this karna behavior and
therefore some go crush it I am prepared
to raise your salary sir yes sir sound
guy raise yourself and promise to
purchase you a new iMac and to properly
monetize all of taurine Akkad Eretz
videos for this Christmas and everyone
Hereafter Merry Christmas sound guy piss
off and so it was said of Ebenezer
YouTube that he was no longer a dick
unfortunately he had alienated all of
his colleagues who built his great
fortune before him and they went forth
and kept the original spirit of YouTube
in their hearts all year round and they
kept it well as for Ebenezer YouTube
well they would rather seem he screwed
the pooch and as were tiny not gay Jared
and his aides
god bless us everyone
[Music]
life is full of big surprises some of
them are [ __ ] you build them up and
YouTube tries to demolish it throughout
all our contents to monetize it all but
look - all of my club and no that will
stand strong screw them all oh who can
here as YouTube tries to instill fear -
silent speech and try to tell us what to
say send so tell them to call - how
screw them wall and through my club we
never have to give up no we don't need
to live in fear with my club we create
content everywhere screw them all with
wire brush our spirits they will never
crush with my club now we can stand tall
no matter what they do we can say screw
them all with my club
we can stand trial
what youtube dies you can say screw them
[Music]
the end of 2017 our last show that was
16 hours 16 so 10 hours it's not
necessarily an entire I don't have all
my mental faculties
we'll see you January for Thursday at
the next show there'll be some change my
mind videos and videos up on the YouTube
channel up at CR TV join a lot of credit
accomplished month up if we haven't
earned your mouth of subscribership here
today then there is no pleasing you we
will see you
January 4th Merry Christmas everyone
[Music]